- I look completely different.
- Oh yeah.
- Just wanted to
point that out.
I know we like brushed
over that, but yeah.
Friendship with Joey
the Anime Man has ended.
I'm Josh the Manga Lad now.
- [Connor] Yeah, you look
like the hacker character
in the movie that doesn't wanna explain
how the hacking works.
(Joey laughing)
(mellow music)
- Am I going crazy or has
the internet gotten the worst
in the past five years?
Am I crazy?
- I don't think you're crazy at all.
- I feel like it's gotten
significantly worse.
Not the whole internet, but the way,
as in the level of fucked up shit that's,
- Yeah, yeah.
Maybe there was, there was
a lot of messed up stuff
five, six years ago or whatever.
But I feel like now, it's
all just out there now.
- I feel like its,
- It's just so normal.
- It's so interesting how
it's almost an opposite effect
that's happening.
Somehow, for some reason,
even though the internet,
or the internet culture
and people on the internet
in the past five, six years,
have gotten more PC than ever before,
and yet, almost counterintuitively,
there's more fucked up
shit that has like come out
onto the surface as well.
- I think that's why,
- In like retaliation, maybe?
Yeah, the more you go PC,
the more that these people-
- Because like I see shit
now on regular Twitter
and Instagram that you'd only ever find
on the fuckin' /b/ board.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's weird, man,
'cause you're just like,
am I weird for being middle
ground on everything?
Like I feel like I have very
normal opinions on things
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah.
- But the more I'm online, I'm like,
am I not normal?
Do I have not normal opinions?
- Yeah, what is a normal opinion anymore?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Just being, I feel like being fair.
I don't really have heavy opinions on,
well, I see other people,
I'm like oh my god.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Common sense has definitely
become less common.
That's for sure.
- I know, it's weird.
- I don't know what's
common sense anymore.
- Yeah, it does feel
like is this the point
where the older generation
starts shit-talking
the newer generation?
You know what I mean?
- Like these damn kids!
- Yeah, 'cause did you ever think like-
- No, I think it's the opposite.
I think it's because the
internet in general has become
more accessible to every age group
that we're seeing all of this.
- Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- 'Cause before it was just 20 year olds
who gave enough fucks to go on-
- [Joey] Like social media or something.
- Yeah.
And I felt that it was
a very exciting time,
and everyone was really into it,
and new websites popped up.
- [Joey] The new hip thing.
- Miniclip was still thriving,
you know.
- Ah, rest in peace.
- FarmVille was still going strong.
(Joey laughing)
- Mafia City.
I'm just gonna keep naming.
- The good old days, man,
the good old days.
- But you know,
I feel like now, because
it's become so normalized
and everyone uses it.
Everyone, right?
- Yeah.
- Like do you remember a
point where it felt like
there was a separation between
what you did on the internet
and what happened in real life?
- Oh, absolutely.
- And I feel like when that
barrier kind of got broken,
where you felt like what happened
in the internet was pertaining
to your active, your,
How can I say this?
Because internet is real life,
but it didn't feel so suffocating.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- You know, it didn't feel
like it had a tangible effect
on your day to day life.
But now it feels like whatever's
going on in the internet,
whatever's going on in the
world, has this tangible effect,
this tangible effect
on what's going on in,
what you're doing in your life.
- You literally just explained the plot
to "Serial Experiments Lain."
- Oh yeah, I kinda am, aren't I.
- That's literally what that is.
- Wait, so what's the
time you think it is?
I'm curious if you have
the same opinion on this.
- What?
- You said the time when
it felt like that became.
- The time when it felt
it became like that?
I don't know.
- I feel it depends
on how long you've been on the internet.
Right?
- Yeah.
- Did you ever do like MySpace?
- No, I came right after MySpace.
- Did you do MySpace?
- No.
- Did you have Bebo?
- I had Bebo.
- I did not.
- That was very popular in the UK.
- Okay.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Would you say, so the
Bebo and MySpace era, right?
So, roughly the same time I would say.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right?
When you were on Bebo
and when people on
MySpace were on MySpace,
did you see that as this
is me, completely tangible
to real life?
- No, it was a game.
Social media's a game.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- It's like how I go into Sims,
and I make myself look attractive in Sims.
- Yeah, 'cause like that's
how I kind of treated MySpace
as well at the time.
- It's a game.
Right? It's like a
- A way to up those
social game.
serotonin points.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's like, I think the
first time I really thought
of social media as a game was actually,
So Charlie Brooker,
do you know Charlie Brooker?
He wrote Black Mirror.
- Yeah.
- So a few years ago, or
maybe even a decade ago,
I can't even remember
how old this video is,
he did a Top 50 most
influential games of all time,
and number one was Twitter.
(Joey laughing)
And I was like what are you
talking about Charlie Brooker?
'Cause before that he talked about,
you know, games like fucking
- That's not a game.
"Last of Us",
fucking "Tetris,"
- Yeah.
you know, all these games.
And he was just like,
well, think about it.
You play as an avatar
on an online platform
where you gain points for
interacting with the game.
And I'm just like, yeah,
I mean, he's very right.
He's, social media at
this point is a game,
and we are all, the game now is our job.
You know, it is our job 'cause-
- We've fallen right into the system.
- We are part of the system guys.
- Dammit.
- We can't criticize the system
'cause we are the system.
- We are the system.
- We are part of the system.
But that is definitely how
social media has become.
And I mean in a way, I see,
especially YouTube and stuff,
as a kind of a game.
I mean, it's been gamified to fuck.
- [Connor] Yeah, it is a game.
- You post a video, and it
even puts you on a leaderboard
on how well it's performed
in the past 10 uploads you've done.
- But the game, the stakes to
it are whatever you give it.
- Yeah.
- Mm.
- You know, a game is, it's
the same with anything, right?
Like, you know, fuckin'
"Jump King" whatever,
whatever it is.
- It's been zero days.
- The game only means
whatever you assign to it.
- Yeah.
- Right?
So with the videos, right?
If you are making these
videos for the purpose
of cracking that one out of 10, then yeah.
But, if you're just making the video
'cause you want to make a video?
I wouldn't say it's game.
- I think when though,
yeah, when you get to that point,
it's like you're kind
of testing the limits
on what you can call a game, right?
Like, you know, is the
stock market a game?
(Conner sputtering)
- Well, yeah hmm.
A game that ruins your life.
- Some people say yes.
Some people say yes. Some people say no.
- It's roulette with extra steps.
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah.
- It's roulette with
massive repercussions.
(Garnt laughing)
- It's roulette where there's
a really, really boring option
that will probably pay you back,
or you can spin the wheel.
- Yeah.
- Spin the wheel.
- Ooh, Dogecoin.
(all laughing)
- You know, come on, I mean.
- It's like "Deal or No Deal"
but it's actually serious.
- Yeah.
- I felt like the,
I don't know when the
internet started to become
very, very real, if you will.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
- But it definitely
jacked up to 100 at 2016.
I think that was when it definitely like-
- Why 2016?
- Presidential election.
- Huh?
- Trump's presidential election.
- Oh.
- I feel like that's
when it just went boom.
That's when the split went crazy.
I felt like the left leaning internet,
right leaning internet,
just went really full on.
- I feel like it was before that.
- I think it might be earlier,
and it's just that we
weren't really aware of it.
- You know what it was?
- That's what I'm saying.
- I'm saying it might
not have started then,
but that's when the dial went fucking 500.
- Yeah.
- You know when it was?
It's when YouTube Rewind
started becoming shit.
(Connor laughing)
- Okay, tell me your
theory, tell me your theory.
- I don't know because-
- What was that, like 2014?
- 2014 about.
- Okay, okay.
- I don't know.
I'm just thinking back,
and I'm just thinking one YouTube Rewind-
- As in when everything on the internet
stopped being universally loved.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Basically when we start
like being segmented,
I just tried to verbalize how
I felt, and I'm just like,
kind of feels around the
same time that I stopped
giving a shit about YouTube Rewind.
- Yeah.
- So that kind of feels like
it was 2014, 2013 maybe.
- Something like that.
- Very early on, when the internet stopped
being one conglomeration, and
you'd see things happening,
and you just didn't recognize
who this person was,
who that person was,
people stopped getting
along and, you know,
factions and groups started to form.
- Yeah, but that's why I took something
like the presidential election,
which is like the most televised
horse race in existence,
if you will.
- Yeah.
It's like, it's so,
You know, other countries,
we don't, you know, the UK,
it's like, yeah, we have this whole thing
about who the new Prime
Minister is gonna be,
but we don't nearly make it
as exciting as America does.
America's so good at making hype.
- I mean, I feel like,
- Yeah.
- I feel like it was the perfect event
that was so polarizing
and so well telegraphed
with so much information
and so many parties
putting stuff into it,
- I think it-
regardless of your opinion on it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And who you voted for,
I don't give a shit.
I'm just saying you can't ignore the fact
that this was a thing that
just really took the internet
and just fucking ran with it.
- Yeah, I think it's also
around the time, roughly,
when a lot of social media sites were,
where that kind of discussion
was just becoming more open.
Like that was roughly around the time
where Twitter increased
their character limit.
- [Connor] Yeah that, right.
- So people could only
tweet about yay Obama won,
and that was it.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- And now it's like, let me
write a full fuckin' novel
about how I feel about
this presidential election.
- And then, you know,
after that is when the platform started
having to correct misinformation,
and that further caused more of a divide.
And then now there's
just different platforms
for different opposing views.
So now you don't even get
to hear the other side.
You're in a echo chamber.
- Yeah, I feel like what
was so prevalent about
not just the presidential election,
but just that year in general,
was that it felt like that
was the real turning point
for where social media kind
of felt just like a TV show.
It was like a part of
entertainment, right, where-
- Well, the presidential election
is the best rated TV show of all time,
I'd probably say.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Everyone tunes in the
watch the next episode.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah. I mean like, it even
had like a buildup season,
which was Brexit, right?
(Joey and Connor laughing)
We had like the mid-season-
- Was that the pilot episode?
- No, no, that was the
mid-season twist, right?
(Joey laughing)
We had the mid-season twist
and we're like, guys, this
show can't get any better.
There's no possible way
they can surprise me.
Jokes on you.
- You'll never expect what comes next.
(Garnt laughing)
- Just fucking look, right?
Look at how they decide the nominee
for the presidential thing.
Look at that shit.
It's laid out like "Who
Wants to be a Millionaire."
Have you seen them all there?
- Yeah.
They're in this semicircle
with all this amazing
fucking TV show-esque "Britain's
Got Talent" background,
and they all take turns,
massive audience and shit.
What is this shit?
- Yeah.
- Like, what, who gives a shit?
Let the party pick, and then
we'll fucking decide who wins.
This whole thing is so
reality TV show-esque.
It's so bizarre.
- Yeah.
When you sit down and you're
like, what am I watching?
Like, this is fucked up.
- Yeah.
Like, okay, here's a question.
Do you think that people
cared about politics
as much before, and we
were just too ignorant,
because we were too young at the time?
Or do you think people care more now,
because of the prevalence of social media
and just so many people
verbalizing their opinions
and their political views?
- I don't think it has
to do with the amount
of people caring, I
think it just has to do
with how much we are
just exposed to it now.
- Yeah, so I think one
of the main things here
is that you have to bear in mind as well
that I think like with the internet,
this has just given everyone the platform.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So like before,
if you wanted to get
support as a politician,
you had to go on a TV show
and say something, right?
You only had like what, one minute?
- Or if you're in Japan,
you blare out of a fucking
megaphone in the street.
Annoyingly.
- True, true, true.
- So now it's like, okay,
so you have the kind of perfect storm
of now there's more ways to discuss,
everyone's on the internet,
now even 40, 50 year
olds are on the internet.
So they're willing to listen to you.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Combine that with the fact
that it's become really easy
to give politics a kind of tribalism
with nothing to do with it, right?
So the whole vaccination
thing or whatever,
and all that nonsense,
not that vaccines are nonsense,
but the whole argument around it.
- Yeah.
- It very quickly stopped
becoming about the science
and more just about which
horse are you backing.
- Yeah.
- So I feel like now-
- It became a political thing.
- It's gotten really easy
to just assign identities
to certain political views.
- Yeah.
- And this has how
politicians have realized
that they can push their agenda.
- Yeah.
- It's by just giving it like,
are you a real American?
Then you'll believe in this.
Right?
It used to be before I felt
like it was just about, more so,
it was this is the policy,
this is what we're gonna do.
And now it's like, all right,
we have to give everything a meaning.
You're either with us or you're not.
Here's the meaning between it,
and all that kind of shit.
I could explain this better
if I was more eloquent with my words,
but unfortunately that isn't the case.
- I mean, they did that subtly
with the whole Ebola crisis, right?
That was the exact same thing.
It suddenly became are you with
us, or are you not with us?
Do you care about these people?
Then you should be with me.
But it's got nothing to do with anything.
- In what case, sorry?
With the Ebola stuff,
like what do you mean?
- Well, it very quickly
became, especially in America,
became a political drive, right?
For the campaigns and whatnot.
And it's just like, well-
- Oh, did it?
- Yeah.
- Oh, I don't remember.
- Yeah, it absolutely did.
And then when the actual
election finished,
everyone stopped talking about it.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Because it's as if it had nothing to do
with the American elections.
- Yeah, because I think it's much easier
instead of proving yourself right,
to prove the other person wrong.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- By proving the other person wrong,
you are in a sense proving yourself right,
even though that's not
how it works at all,
you know?
(Joey laughing)
Like when did Ben Shapiro
start owning people
with facts and logics?
Because I feel like that's
when it started, you know.
- Around same time I believe.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Probably around the same time.
- When it wasn't about
being involved in politics,
it was just you start
off watching someone else
just owning other people
with their logistical,
logical arguments or whatever, you know,
it became part of entertainment.
- It's like the, what's this
guy, the "Prove me Wrong" guy.
- Oh, um.
- Stephen Crowder.
- Stephen Crowder, right?
- Yeah.
- Like that as well,
just like fuckin' exploded
out of nowhere too,
for the same reasons.
- It's weird how seeing
these waves come up.
First, it's just like,
you have the group that
proves the other group wrong.
And then after a while
people get bored of that.
And then it's people
proving that group wrong.
And it's a constant,
it's a constant ping pong fuckin' match.
- As well, you know, there's
information on a lot of things.
There's always way more nuance
than people want to get into.
Right?
- Yeah.
- So a lot of the time,
if you just take one correct argument,
or one correct fact, about
a flawed argument, right?
You can just run with that, and push that,
and say look, this is right.
Even though in context,
it might be incorrect,
but you can just keep
running with something that
you know that you can
parrot and is safe to do so.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And even then, even if you're
wrong, it doesn't matter.
'Cause as we've learned is
that if you're a narcissist
and you're willing to not give a fuck
if people are trying to cancel you.
- Yeah.
- People have learned that
canceling only does shit
if you give a fuck.
- Yeah.
- And people are being
rewarded en mass, you know?
And a lot of those people are like that,
who, even though they get shit wrong,
as long as they don't give a fuck,
and they just make something new
or don't mention it and just continue on,
it doesn't matter.
You get what you want,
you get your platform, you continue,
you can get new followers.
Oh, you lost a few hundred followers?
Oh, you'll get a new thousand.
Who cares?
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
There's never been more of a
time when I've realized that,
you know, bad, what
was it, like bad press?
Like there is no such thing as bad,
- Bad press.
- There's no such thing as bad press.
- It's as bad as you give a shit.
- Yeah.
- The thing is, as well, is a
lot of people have realized,
and you see this on YouTube
as well in influencers,
it's as bad as you let
it seem it is, as well.
So if you are like, that's
why a lot of the scandals
around the presidential
election that happened in 2016,
a lot of them,
because if the guy who you
are supporting is like,
it's not a big deal, then
maybe you'll be like,
oh, it's not a big deal.
- Yeah, I guess not.
- Yeah, yeah, you know.
There is a kind of,
it's as bad as they let it seem, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- If you address it and be
like, I don't give a fuck,
or you don't even bother to
address it then, you know?
- Yeah, I mean, I think
you're right in a sense,
and I feel like even more so,
it was when Trump got elected, you know,
regardless of your opinion
of him as a president,
for me as an outsider who is, you know,
not any part of American politics,
it was almost like watching a
character in a show, you know?
- It was, it was.
- Going on your Twitter timeline
and seeing some of the
stuff that he tweeted.
- It was like a cartoon villain.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Remember like the whole covfefe shit?
(Garnt laughing)
I don't care where you lie
in the political spectrum,
I think we can all unanimously agree
that covfefe was fuckin' hilarious.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah.
- And yeah, it kind of, I
dunno what the right word is,
but it kind of cartoonified shit.
- Yeah.
- It kind of like cartoonified
your real life and you know,
the world events, even though,
even though these were
real prevalent issues,
and these had a real, tangible-
- There's nothing cartoony about it.
- These had a real, tangible
effect on the world.
And I feel like,
especially a lot of the younger generation
who have grown up in
the age of the internet,
that's kind of the environment
they've grown into,
you know?
- Yeah.
- Where everything, when
it's seen through a phone
or through a tablet, they just like-
- It's like suddenly not real.
- Yeah, 'cause we were, what, 20 plus
when all this started happen,
Oh, no, 20?
Maybe I was like 19.
But like, I couldn't
imagine going from 12 to 18.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And this has been
your entire memory.
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is weird.
- Like, it's really bizarre.
- It's crazy.
- And you know, we don't
really talk about it
on the podcast, our political views
or our political opinions,
because at the most part
I don't give a fuck what you believe in.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I have my own opinions,
but I'm also not,
I don't think I'm some kind of
benevolent man who knows all.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- I know that I have probably
come to conclusions on things
through flawed thinking, methodology,
whatever the fuck you say.
- Yeah.
Just 'cause of how I've
been raised, right?
And you've been raised
whatever way you have.
And if you disagree with me on this,
I don't give a fuck how you
came to that conclusion.
I'm not gonna judge you.
And I feel like one of
the biggest problems
that's come out of all this,
is that everyone's
calling each other stupid
for believing in something.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, I'm
sure you have a reason.
If we just spoke to each other normally
and didn't polarize each
other all the fucking time,
we might have a conversation.
- Just to, you know,
agree to disagree, right?
It's like, we're not here to
fucking dangle a fucking carrot
in front of your face being like
believe us, because we hold the truth.
And it's like, no, no one does.
- Sucks as well,
'cause obviously with the
whole coronavirus stuff,
and that all got politicized,
because of course it did.
- Of course it did.
- That, unfortunately, came
at the cost of people's lives.
- Yeah.
- And you know, the people
who felt they were right,
felt so strongly they were right,
'cause they thought that,
you know, they're like,
yeah, we have to protect people.
And yeah, that's fair enough.
But it's kind of difficult
to convince people
when you're calling them stupid.
- Yeah.
- It's been shown that
it just doesn't work.
- No.
- No, no.
I mean, I think another big, massive thing
with the age of the internet is just
the fucking overload of information.
- Yeah.
- Right?
Where it's like, I remember a point where,
you know, you'd read something in a book
or read a newspaper or something,
and you'd educate yourself.
But it feels like
there is just so much
information right now
that I don't even know what information is
the right information to educate myself.
- [Connor] Right, right.
- A lot of the time.
- So many times.
So many times I look at something
online and I think like,
oh man, this is a kind of
interesting piece of information.
Couple of hours later, I
find out it's total bullshit.
It's like what the fuck?
(Garnt laughing)
- Welcome to real life.
- Literally every time,
I'm just like, how?
- It's so true,
where sometimes you hear
about a story or an event,
and you're like, fuck
man, that fuckin' sucks.
- I get told by five or six
different people being like,
have you seen this thing?
And I'm like, well fuck,
if there's five or six
people around me that I know,
and I understand,
- Yeah.
who's telling me that this is happening,
then it must be true,
and I'm like, turns out, nope.
All bullshit.
- When you were a kid, right,
did you think that people were stupid?
Like you think that you're too smart.
- In what context?
- Just in general, as a kid,
I was one of those little kids
that just thought in school,
I think half the reason why
I was angry half the time
was because I thought, this is so dumb.
I'm smarter than all this.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- [Connor] Right.
- I can't even remember.
- Yeah.
- I just wanted to play video games.
I didn't really give a shit.
- [Connor] Right, right.
- I didn't feel that
strongly about things.
- So I thought, as a kid, I
just thought I was smarter
than people around me.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Right?
- I think everyone had that phase though.
- Right, right.
But I think people don't grow out of it,
some people don't
grow out of it.
- Yeah.
Some people grow don't grow
out of it obviously, yeah.
- Because, and it's really interesting,
'cause I was just scrolling on Reddit.
- Yeah.
- God forbid.
- I saw this, and it was
a post where it was like,
I think everyone else is dumb,
and it's infuriating
having to talk to people.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- And then it was really
interesting seeing
how people were trying to reply to this,
and break it down.
- Right.
- And ultimately, and I
think this is really good,
and I think that everyone
should keep this in mind.
Because I feel that we judge
people based on how they speak,
not how their level of intelligence is.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And I feel like this definitely
happens on the podcast.
I've seen it in the comment section,
where we might have a bad take,
or we might badly explain something.
- Yeah.
- And everyone's like,
well Connor's dumb, or
Joey's dumb, Garnt's dumb.
He couldn't explain this.
- Yeah.
- It's so hard to grasp.
We only can interact with people
based on the things they say, right?
Not how they think.
'Cause you are probably
thinking about things
way deeper than you could ever explain
about it, right?
- Oh yeah, of course.
And it's so hard to get
that out of your head
when someone's talking to you,
'cause you only have
that to work off, right?
- I mean, it's a skill,
and that's why I have trouble
properly expressing myself
unless it's written down.
- Yeah.
Which is why I script.
- Right, right.
- Which we can't do on the podcast.
- Which we can't do on the
podcast, unfortunately.
But we can't edit it either.
So that's why I know for a
fact that I express myself best
in text form or written form,
when it's written down.
- But also on the podcast, I
think you're quite eloquent
with the way you word things.
And I think-
- Yeah, I think so.
- I mean, I've had some pretty shit takes.
- Oh, me too, me too.
- We all have.
- Just because I was,
There has been several points
where I look at myself
arguing an argument,
and I'm just like, I'm a fucking clown.
I deserve to be fucking clowned on.
- Some true "bruh" moments.
- That has been a thing in
the Trash Takes comments.
It's been a normal thing
where they'll be like,
I get what Connor's saying,
but he explained it badly.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
And I will admit, I'm
extremely guilty of that.
I do that a lot.
- Yeah.
And there are a lot of
things that I try to explain,
but in the moment, it's
just hard to get the words.
Because we don't come into
this, it's not a debate.
We don't script this shit.
We just turn up-
- Yeah.
- We don't.
- It's like, I get what you mean,
but you probably should
have double-checked this.
(Joey laughing)
- Like the whole, the
fuckin' food illness thing.
If you gave me 20 minutes in a room alone
and I could write?
I could probably prepare
a decent argument.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- However I don't.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
- If you gave me time to
put it in an essay form,
I'm sure I could tell you.
- But also, this is how
real life is and it's weird,
'cause I feel like when I
watch people as well speak,
and again, this is going back
to how just general life,
again, this ties into the previous topics
with the online, right?
How we respond to people who
have bad opinions on things
or we observe to be bad opinions.
It's so hard in this
current climate online
to just give people the
benefit of the doubt.
- Yeah.
- And just be like I think you mean well,
and I don't think this opinion you have,
that could be hurting people,
I don't think you genuinely
want to hurt people.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It could be you've just been misinformed
and you believe it.
- Yeah.
- You genuinely think
this is helping people.
- That's the problem
though, is that, I feel,
you know, a lot of social media,
like Twitter, Reddit, stuff like that,
is 99% emotionally driven.
- Yeah.
- That's just humanity.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, that too, but also, you know,
a lot of people like to think that,
oh, I see this massive post
on, you know, massive comment
replying to a certain shit
take on Reddit, right?
- Yeah.
- And they think like,
oh, judging from the
length of this whole thing,
this must be a very well-thought,
well-written argument.
90% of the time, no.
It's emotional drivel.
But that's unfortunately
how the nature of a lot
of these internet arguments
- It's depressing.
work, right?
- It's so depressing.
That even when you go on
Reddit, and look at it
and someone will say something
that's a bit incorrect,
and it will just immediately
turn into argument.
Instantly.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Why do you wanna do this?
Don't you wanna?
- Yeah.
- It's like, no one's
fucking citing their sources
in these kinds of comment sections.
It's all, it's all emotional.
- Yeah. I mean that's just
how humans are always.
- Yeah.
- That's why I don't
normally try to get involved
on a platform like Twitter,
because do you think anyone's ever
changed their fucking mind
from like a single tweet
or like a Twitter discussion?
- No.
I can't see it happening.
- I'd love to meet someone who's like,
I thought about this thing,
but then I saw XXXn00bkillerXX
tweet that out,
and be like, yeah, you know what?
You're right, bro.
(Garnt laughing)
Opinion changed.
Just like that.
- Yeah, I've seen threads
that maybe, you know,
we'll just agree to disagree, you know,
with threads that you open
up that show all replies,
and you just keep scrolling
down, and it just never ends.
(Joey laughing)
- The only time I see people
civilized on the internet
and always be really
respectful to each other
is when they're talking about porn.
(Joey cackling)
- Yes, yes.
- That's the only time.
People are so fucking polite to each other
when they're talking about porn,
and they're so helpful,
and everyone's so helpful about it,
but the moment it's
anything else, it's like,
they start going at the throat.
- It's the image of all the board members
at the Roundtable.
(all laughing)
- I think that's very
good example right now.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
It's literally very civilized.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I just love as well the ones that are,
going back to the whole
agreeing to disagree thing.
I've seen so many Twitter replies
of how one side of the
argument tries to start
that whole conclusion up being like,
you know what, let's agree to disagree.
But 90% of the time
the other party's like,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
- Yeah.
- We're not ending it here.
I'm not gonna agree to disagree.
Fuck you.
How dare you?
- You know that people feel,
for some reason, feel safe,
discussing their opinions about
porn and hentai and whatever
'cause on some of these
discord servers,
- Yeah.
where they talk about hentai,
people use their real fucking pictures
as their profile pictures.
(Garnt laughing)
That's how safe they feel talking.
What the fuck?
- That's the real safe space.
- Some people feel, some-
- That is the real space safe space, man.
- What?!
- To me, that is bold.
- It's like, I'm into NTR.
Let's agree to disagree.
(everyone laughing)
Shake hands.
- It's like Steven with
his actual profile picture.
It's like what?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
What?
- This episode is sponsored by honey.
The easy way to save
when shopping on your iPhone or computer.
Guys let's not pretend that we
don't all shop online, right?
- Of course we do.
- But don't you wish you had a promo code,
ready for you always when
you're at the checkout.
- Yes.
- Well, thanks to honey,
manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past.
Honey is a free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one
it finds to your cart,
every time you shop online.
- How does it work, Connor?
- Imagine it.
You're shopping on one
of your favorite sites.
- Um huh.
- Yeah.
- When you're at the checkout,
the honey button appears,
and all you have to do
is click "apply coupons."
- That's all?
- Wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons
it can find for that site.
If honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch the prices drop.
- It's that easy?
- It's that easy.
And recently I just bought a
microphone to upgrade my setup,
and honey saved me 15 bucks
- Whoa.
on a brand new microphone.
- If you don't already have honey,
you can be straight up
missing out on free savings.
- Woo.
- And by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid
and also supporting us as well.
- Oh yeah.
- I'd never recommend
something I don't use.
So get honey for free at
joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
Links in the description below.
- Back to the episode.
- Why is it that the porn community
on Twitter is some of the chillest people?
- The porn community in any community is
the chillest people.
- Isn't it fucked up that a
Pornhub comment section is
more chill than a YouTube comment section?
- I feel 'cause you, to have
to interact in a community
you have to have a level
of self-awareness, I think.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So I think that's where it comes from.
You are just so self-aware
that you just don't give a fuck anymore.
And that's when you're most Zen,
after you've nutted.
- Yeah.
- Well basically, it's a
massive barrier of entry
just to sign up an account
to a porn site, right?
(Joey laughing)
- That's a level that I just
haven't been able to take.
I just don't wanna give my Gmail account.
- I just wanna be at that morning where
I wake up in the morning, like,
I'm making a Pornhub account today.
- This is the most "Trash
Taste" segue ever, by the way.
Can I say that?
That we've gone from
like very serious topics
to signing up to a porn account?
I don't know what kind of person is like,
I need to just have my say in this.
(Joey cackling)
I gotta make it known what I think about-
- I feel like there's steps,
because I've never signed
up for a Pornhub account.
- Yeah.
- But I have for like hentai sites, right?
- Right.
- You have?
- Yeah.
- I have, yeah.
- Because sometimes you find a lit hentai,
and you're like, I want to remember this,
because I'm going to
forget the name afterwards.
- I will say, as a free to
play user of the porn universe,
I will say the most annoying thing is
trying to find a video that I did enjoy.
- Yeah, 'cause the problem is, you know,
after you do the deed, you're
not interested in it anymore.
So you're like, I don't
fucking need this anymore.
And then it just goes out the recesses
of your mind and fucking
a week later you're like,
yo, what was that fucking A class hentai
that I found the other week?
- There is a sobering moment
when you're trying to type
in the keywords to find the thing.
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
- And you are like, I'm disgusting.
(everyone laughing)
And you're just scrolling
through these videos,
trying to find it.
You're like, no, no, there's
something wrong with me.
- I've gone to the point
where I've anonymously gone
onto forums and asked.
- Have you actually?
- No, no you haven't.
- I have.
(Garnt laughing)
- What's your profile pic?
- I'm not telling you.
Do you know what anonymous means?
- It's gotta be Joey.
I want it to be like, yeah,
'cause no one would ever
expect the Joey to use
his actual profile picture on the forum.
- That's true.
- But now everyone's gonna use Joey.
- Now everyone's gonna use Joey.
- Yeah, 'cause I didn't know
anyone at the time, right?
And I was in the exact same
situation where I was like,
I just saw this thing,
but it was on incognito.
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
So I don't remember what it was called.
All I remember is what
the girl looked like.
- If you could log in, do you
know the login information?
Do you still use this account?
- No, not anymore.
I don't even think the
website exists anymore.
- Yeah, that is the one
problem with incognito mode.
Is that it doesn't give
you a search history.
- Yeah.
- Or a history.
- Like the moment the
post nut clarity hits
and you close that window,
you're like, shit!
Why did I do that?
(Garnt laughing)
I can't go back now.
- Oh my God.
- So yeah, one time, I remember it.
I remember what the girl looked like,
and I remember a certain scene.
So I was just like, hey, I'm
looking for this one series.
These are the details.
Help appreciated.
Immediately, five people
came back being like,
I think it's this one.
You should look it up.
None of them were actually it,
but I got great recommendations.
- But you got some new
recommendations along the way.
- I was like, oh sick,
that's pretty close.
- What about signing up for,
Well, I guess it depends,
'cause in Hentai and stuff
it's different.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Normal one, I dunno what
would compel me to want pay.
- What do you mean?
- Like a pay site?
- I wouldn't wanna give
fucking my credit card
to one of these sites.
Dude, that feels like such a,
you know, when you hear about these,
which one was it?
Was it the New York guy who was running
for mayor of New York.
- Right.
- Anthony Wiener, was it?
- Something like that.
- No, there was somebody who got-
- Anthony Wiener was one with dick pics.
- Yeah, that was it.
No, there was someone else who was,
they were running for political position,
and then it was found
out they were spending
five grand a month on
pornography or something.
And I was like, that's
impressive that you manage
to find ways to spend five grand.
- No, that is impressive.
- You're definitely not watching
all of it, that's for sure.
- Yeah.
- Cause how could you?
I don't think one person is capable
of watching that much porn.
- How many, like, yeah.
How many OnlyFans was he like sub to?
- Right, yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- How many terabytes worth?
- We spoke about this, right?
'Cause remember we spoke
about that one YouTuber
who had a porn addiction and-
- Yes, yes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I don't remember who it was.
I do remember, yeah, that sounds familiar.
- It was like the most
Chad YouTuber apology,
not apology, video.
- Yeah.
He was like, he was never
accused of anything.
He just came out, he's like,
guys, I have a porn addiction.
It's rough.
I was like-
- Yeah, well it was like
literally ruining his life.
Right?
- Yeah, well it's one of those
things that I can always,
I always fucking say,
"it's one of those things."
Goddamn, I gotta stop saying that.
Connor, this is a message you.
Stop saying it.
- It's one of those things.
- Question to you, Connor.
- It is literally my "a question to you."
I, it's one of those things, um,
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
That people talk about, and oh,
people do not talk about enough-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And it's one of those things,
people don't wanna give
credit to it or talk about it
'cause it's just really embarrassing and-
- Yeah, of course.
- Don't give credit to
how debilitating it can be
to have that.
If you have it, man, I
hope you can get help.
I hope you can get out of it.
No shame to you, man.
It's so hard.
- It happens.
- It's 'cause it's
something that's just like,
it doesn't seem on the forefront of things
you should be worried about, you know?
- Definitely right.
- Like, you know, you can easily,
it's easy to be able
to justify to yourself,
oh yeah, a gambling addiction,
of course that's bad.
You know or like-
- It ruins your life directly.
- Or like an alcohol addiction,
or I'm just kind of destroying my body.
I'm destroying all my
relationships around me.
A porn addiction, because
porn is so secretive anyway,
you don't really have
anyone to talk to it about.
- It's not an immediate threat,
I think is the thing.
- Yeah.
'Cause you hear about, yeah,
of course I watch porn.
I'm an adult.
It's everyone does it.
It's fine.
You know, everyone, most
people are living normal lives,
you know, while watching it,
and then you go down the
rabbit hole deep enough
and you realize, oh it's actually fucked.
It's just as bad.
- At which point do you accept
that it is an addiction,
and not just a recreational
activity that everyone does?
You know what I mean?
- I think like, I don't know.
- It's tough.
'Cause when are games
too addicting, right?
When are you addicted
to games?
- Yeah.
- Is it the hours spent
consuming that medium
or is it the money spent
consuming that medium?
Or is it both?
(Connor blowing through lips)
- I don't know.
- Is it when you can't think
of anything other than porn?
- 'Cause no one wants to
help people who are addicted
to porn 'cause they
don't think it's a thing.
- Yeah, 'cause they are
like just stop watching it.
(Garnt laughing)
Just turn it off.
- Just stop jacking off.
- Just close your eyes.
(all laughing)
Just put your dick away, it's easy.
- To me, I guess I don't know
what the actual definition
of addiction is,
but I guess when you should
start being worried about it is
when it has a tangible
effect on maybe your life
in some way, shape or form.
But like what-
- Like affecting negatively.
- Yeah, that's it.
Like a tangible, negative
effect on your life
or an aspect of your life.
But then again, when does
it become a negative effect
and when does it just
become like, oh yeah,
I just had a week binge
drinking with the boys,
because we are like
partying all week, you know?
Like, at which point does
it become a negative effect?
I don't know.
I guess that's the hard thing about it.
And it becomes-
- I think it's when, in my
opinion, I think it's when
it's consistently, for
a long period of time,
and it's consistently just
adding onto a negative effect.
I think that's when it becomes
like a problematic addiction.
Because you can, as you said,
you could have like a week binge
of drinking from morning to
night with the boys, right?
- Yeah.
- But you're most likely
not gonna be drinking
for a while after that, right?
I wouldn't count that as an addiction.
That's like a short term binge.
- That's just destroying your body.
- Yeah that's just destroying your body
and having a good time with the boys.
But when it's a constant amount every day,
or for a long period of time consistently.
- Yeah.
- And it's just getting worse
and worse and worse and worse,
I think that's when it's like,
okay, you should probably seek help.
In my opinion, I don't know.
- It's when you sign up
to a Pornhub account.
- It's when you're like, you know what?
I need people to know how I
feel about that blowjob scene.
It was so good.
(Garnt laughing)
I need up votes on my Pornhub comment.
- That's the one thing I don't understand.
I understand, the thing about
porn hub comments is that,
I understand people asking about
fucking Call of Duty's tactics
or fucking how to get past this level,
- [Connor] (indistinct)
- Rather than people actually
commenting on the porn itself.
Like to me, for some reason,
I dunno why you would ever
comment on a porno, right?
Because you are either like watching it
and you're actively involved,
or I've never gotten to a
point where watching this,
I'm just like, I want to
verbalize what I think about-
- What do people think about this?
- What I think about this, you know.
- My favorites are the ones
that are just so simple,
so innocent being like, oh
man, 18:23, what a hot scene.
I was like, yeah?
I guess so.
(Garnt laughing)
Thank you for sharing that.
Didn't need to know.
- I wish I was that open.
I wish I was that way.
- Yeah.
- Maybe one day, maybe one day.
(Joey giggling)
- What, do you wanna get to that point?
- Who knows?
Who knows, Joey?
- I don't know.
- Have you seen some
of the fucking shit that
Sydney's been tweeting?
You know, I need to fucking
calm her down sometimes.
- Yeah, yeah.
I wouldn't be surprised if
she had a Pornhub account.
- At this point, I
think it's just Twitter.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- She's gone beyond.
- Yeah, she's gone beyond, man.
- So why be anonymous
when I could be known?
- Oh God.
- Jesus.
- Anyway, have you guys been
up to anything this past week
that's not been depressing or?
- I look completely different.
- Oh yeah.
- Just wanted to point that out.
I know we brushed over that, but yeah.
Friendship with Joey
the Anime Man has ended.
I'm Josh the Manga Lad now.
(Garnt laughing)
Just the comments,
so I got my ears pierced.
That's one big thing.
- Yes.
And then just yesterday I got my haircut.
So now I look completely different.
- Yeah, you look like the
hacker character in the movie
that doesn't wanna explain
how the hacking works.
(Joey laughing)
He just kinda like pisses everyone off.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But they always need him.
- Yeah, yeah, the one that-
- You like like that guy now.
- Yeah, I look like
that guy now.
(Connor laughing)
But I just loved so, you know,
'cause I had the, every time,
I feel this is very much a YouTuber thing,
but even if you slightly change
how you look,
- Yeah.
or slightly do something different, right?
To some people it's like, what the fuck?
It's the end of the world
type of thing, right?
- I think it's just YouTube
comments work on the first thing
they think they can comment
about, they comment.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So it's always the appearance
'cause you see that first.
- Yeah, and it's like,
every time I get my hair cut
or I shave or you know, I
guess in this case, you know,
drastically changed quite a bit.
Just my favorite things is
seeing the reception to it,
regardless of if it's
positive or negative.
To all the people who said
like, hey Joey, you look good.
I appreciate that.
That's fucking dope.
Thank you.
But my favorites are
the ones that of people
losing their minds in a negative sense.
Like a family member
just died.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What was the funniest response you got?
- The funniest one,
So the one I saw on Insta,
it's always Instagram
that are the best ones.
- Okay, okay.
When I got the, when I posted the pictures
of getting my ears pierced,
the top comment for a while was
is he gay or European?
(crew member laughing)
And I was like, yes, I am a JoJo fan.
Thank you.
(all laughing)
But then, you know, with
the haircut, for instance,
you know, some people
were like, hey, you know,
I like your cut G you
know, you always get those.
And then other ones were like, you know,
I can't believe it.
L + ratio.
(Garnt laughing)
He fell off.
- You fell off.
- I saw one,
I saw a quote retweet
that was dead ass saying
you fucking fell off.
- You fell off.
And I was like, what because-
- Well, his hair definitely
did fall off.
- You did fall off.
- My hair fell off, that's for sure.
- I was like, what?
Because I got a haircut?
- It was the same when I moved to Japan.
In the same video I also dyed my hair.
- Yeah.
- And even though I'd moved to Japan,
half the comments were
like, oh my God, his hair.
(Joey laughing)
I was like, I just moved to Japan!
What the fuck?
- Yeah, like your hair is,
oh, I have different hairs.
You know, responsible for
different funnies now.
- Like what?
- It's just hair!
- I just like the fact
that you've had longer hair
and the same length hair.
Now you have shorter hair.
- To be fair, this is the
shortest I think I've ever had it.
- Yeah.
- And it's weird.
- [Connor] Does it feel good?
- It feels good.
The back of my hair feels good, yeah.
But it's like, I don't know-
- Easy to how easy is it to wash now?
- Oh dude, it's like-
- That's the best part
about having short hair.
- It's amazing.
I love it.
But like, yeah, I don't know.
So many people are like,
why would you do that to yourself?
It's like-
- Why would you do that?
- It's like I fucking stabbed a kid.
It's like, why would you do that now?
And I was like, why not?
- So as some one who rarely
ever changes their hairstyle,
how'd you guys pick what
hairstyle that you do?
Or like, how do you pick a new hairstyle?
- I'm not confident
enough in my own abilities
to ever change my own style.
Somebody else has to do it for me.
- [Garnt] Right, right.
- And then I'm like, oh, oh,
and then I stick with it.
- Yeah, to me, every time I have changed
my hairstyle in my life,
it's been someone else
recommending me a hairstyle
to change it to, and I'm
just like, I don't know
if I'll like this.
I don't know if I'll like this.
And it takes me like a
good year or something,
so I build up my courage to be like, okay,
maybe I'll go for this person's advice.
And I change it and I'm like, okay,
well this is my new hairstyle now.
I'm never changing it again.
- How did you transition
from sasuke hair to now?
- Um.
- Was that a suggestion?
- Yeah, it was a suggestion
by my mates?
- Okay.
Because they were like, mate,
you need to stop putting
this much gel into your fucking hair.
Fucking just comb it down.
And you're like, no, no.
The sasuke hair makes
me, everyone loves it.
Everyone fucking loves it.
- Yeah.
It's never gonna change.
It's like this for the rest of my life.
And I do it once.
I'm like, yeah, the sasuke
hair's fucking stupid.
I dunno what I was thinking.
(Joey laughing)
- I've decided my hairstyle based on
what requires no gel or wax.
I just hate putting shit in my hair.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I always hated that.
So I just like, whatever I
can do when I roll outta bed
is the one I'm going for.
- So envious.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I need-
- Yeah, I know, you've
gone to perfectionist.
It's like hand sculpting the perfect-
- But I mean before today's episode,
like majority of episodes
is just my bedhead.
- Yeah.
- Like I don't do anything with it.
It's so funny though people asking
what shampoo and conditioner do you use?
I was like Head and Shoulders.
Fucking Dove.
Like it's nothing special.
Yeah, I don't know.
For me, it's like, I'm
given this job, right?
Like, YouTubing and being on social media
where it's like, this
isn't gonna fucking affect-
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, you know, my videos, right?
- Yeah.
- It doesn't affect my job.
It's just a matter of personal preference.
So in my head, if I'm
given this opportunity
where I can kind of
experiment with how I look
and it not really affect my job,
maybe it might even affect it
positively for some people,
why wouldn't I try it?
'Cause with my hair, for instance,
if you hate this hair, just wait a month,
it'll grow back to normal.
It's gonna go back to the
length you're comfortable with.
It's fine.
But why would I not give it a go?
- But also I feel like a
lot of that is just people
not being used to a look or a new look.
- Yeah, of course, of course.
- Because I remember when
I first started growing out
a stubble and everyone's like,
oh, you look weird as fuck.
And even I did, I thought,
man, I look fucking weird.
I look fucking weird as
fuck with just a stubble
'cause I've never had a stubble
or I've never like grown
out a stubble in my life,
even though I've always known I could.
And I remember I was
working on my latest vlog
and I was looking at my Trash Taste video
where I talk about Trash Taste.
And then I was looking at
the previous vlog I did
before I was recording this one,
and it was the BBC video
that I did without a stubble.
And I was like, man, I look fucking weird.
(Joey laughing)
Now I think I look
weird without a stubble,
and I look back at all
Trash Taste episodes,
And I'm like, man, I look really weird.
I don't know, man.
- Dude, when you go back to
episode one of Trash Taste
and I'm in a fucking ponytail.
(Garnt laughing)
- Oh my God, I completely
forgot about that.
- I look at that
and I'm like, you look homeless.
I'm so glad I don't look
like this in anymore.
But back then everyone was like,
yeah, the Jesus hair, dude,
it looks fucking sick.
And back then I was like, yeah.
Yeah, you know what?
It kinda looks sick, not gonna lie.
But now I'm just like, no.
It really got to the point
where I knew it was gross
when even Aki's mom who
is the most accepting,
kind, never says a bad
thing about anything,
just one day was like, I think
you should cut your hair.
(all laughing)
I was like, if you are
saying that, maybe I should.
- Yeah, I'd never wanna hear from-
- I think maybe I should.
- The mom.
Not my own mom, Jesus.
- I feel like I needed
to hear that though.
'Cause that's probably how dire I looked.
'Cause now I know what she means.
I look back and then I'm
like, yeah, you know what,
if I saw a guy like
that who I cared about,
I'd probably tell him to cut his hair too.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it's kind of gross.
But it's like, yeah, I don't know.
Even with the piercings
in the ear as well,
it was surprising how a
lot of people were like,
oh, I thought your ears
were already pierced.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And I was like-
- Yeah, now that you say it, I dunno why,
I know it's never been that way,
but you have that energy where
you had your ears pierced.
- Yeah, you did.
You did have that energy.
- Really?
- 'Cause like when you said
you want your ears pierced,
I was like didn't you already
have your ears pierced,
or am I just like dreaming that up?
- Yeah, everyone said that.
I was like, really?
- It is weird how much
just changing a little bit
of your facial features
can change the perception.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- When I was growing out
my beard a little bit,
I looked like fucking Willem
Dafoe from "The Lighthouse."
(Joey laughing)
And I was like, I kind
of digged it though.
But also at the same time, it
was really fucking annoying.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Having it long.
- You actually reminded
me of Linus Tech Tips
more than anything.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Don't say that.
- I don't know why,
just when you grow-
- I don't wanna,
He wears sandals and socks.
I don't wanna-
- Put a side by side of Linus.
(Garnt laughing)
- I love Linus, but
he's not drip, you know?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Like I don't wanna be compared
to Linus when it comes to-
- No, he, I think he
looks good with a beard.
I just like, he wasn't Willem Dafoe,
it was like Linus Tech
Tips with a beard energy
that I got for me.
I dunno.
I take that as a compliment.
- Now, now,
- I think it's a compliment.
- I wanna get rid of it all.
- It's not a dis, it's not a dis.
- It's not a dis, bruv.
- I'd rather be Willem Dafoe.
I hear he has like a 12 inch cock.
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
- Is that the biggest
change you've ever done
aside from like getting your hair dyed
and everything like that,
you've ever done to your-
- I think you turning silver
was the biggest change, right?
- Yeah, that was weird.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- When I look at that, that was weird.
I liked it when it was
half blond, half brown,
kind of like dirty blonde
I think it's called.
- [Joey] Like when the
silver was fading, right?
- Yeah, I liked that.
I liked it towards the end.
- Yeah, I liked segment as well.
- But then it's like, I don't
wanna have to do it again.
Also I probably shouldn't
be dyeing my hair
when I haven't got much left of it, so.
- Apparently that's a myth.
- Is it really?
- Yeah.
- I don't know then.
- My hairdresser was saying yesterday.
- But she got stakes in it.
(Garnt laughing)
It's her job to dye people hair.
- Well, no, yeah, but,
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
That's true, but also she was saying
that unless you're directly
applying the bleach
onto the scalp, which a
hairdresser shouldn't be doing
to begin with, it doesn't affect.
- True.
- I mean, I don't know either way, I'm-
- I know why you're cautious about it.
- I've got outta that phase as well
where I feel like I need to dye my hair.
I feel like I'm in the boomer stage now
where I'm like, it'll do what it does.
- You're in the veteran stage.
- It'll do whatever it wants,
and I will just deal with it.
- It does feel like regardless of age,
it does feel like a stage that
every YouTuber goes through.
- Yeah.
- It's like, oh, it's the dyed,
it's either they go through a bald stage
or they dye their hair.
- But it's the, it's the I'm a YouTuber
with a little bit of clout stage.
(all laughing)
- It's like, oh, people-
- That is kinda like the
YouTuber midlife crisis, right?
- It's like, oh, people
are starting to look at me.
Maybe I should spice things up.
- I remember I never really
wanted to dye my hair.
It was like, I think I was kinda-
- [Joey] What made you want to?
- I think I was kind interested in it.
I was like, I've never tried it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Thought could be interesting.
And then when I met Charlie,
who dyes your hair, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- She was just kinda like,
yeah, let's just do it.
- [Joey] Yeah, just give it a go.
- I was like, I mean, I
think I was in that phase
where I was like, yeah, fuck it.
Everything in my life
was changing, why not?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So I tried it, and I remember
I didn't like it initially.
I thought, okay.
And then it got to blonde, I thought, huh?
Weirdly, looks okay.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I didn't mind blonde.
- Yeah.
But then also it did
make me look a bit weird.
- I don't think the silver
looked weird on you,
to be honest.
I think out of all the,
I think that compared to a red or a blue,
you know, or a,
- Yeah, red is-
you know, a standard,
like I am a YouTuber, YouTube gamer color.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Compared to that, I think-
- YouTube gamer color.
- Ah, Ninja.
Ninja.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- [Garnt] Oh yeah, Ninja.
- That was a strong blue.
- Of you had like,
if you had ninja hair, I
would've been like, uh.
- [Connor] Strong blue.
- Are you a Twitch streamer?
(all laughing)
- I mean, I've done, what?
Five or six different colors now.
I've done red, blue, green, pink, purple.
And now I have this like grayish-
- Complete the rainbow.
- Yeah, I have, yeah.
I have.
- You just wake up one
day and you're just like,
I wanna try something different today.
- Which Starburst color am I doing today?
- Yeah, exactly.
But again, that's an easy
way to date my videos, right?
I know exactly what
era this video is from,
just based on what color my hair is.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So it's kind of cool, but yeah.
I don't know.
If you don't like this,
that's totally fine.
- You'll get used to
it within like a month.
- You'll get used to it.
- As with everyone does.
- Yeah, I'm not even used to it right now.
I woke up this morning, I was like, ah.
Wait, who the fucks' that?
- I'm just praying, I'm like, God, please,
I hope I don't have a weird
shaped head when I go bald.
- Exactly.
- Please, please, please.
- That was the one thing
- Please, please, please,
I was worried about.
'Cause it really shapes out my face.
- I don't know how, how do you know
what the shape of your head is?
- You won't know.
- You don't know do you?
- Until you get to like this
length and you're like, oh,
my head is fucking weird.
- I feel like we should
have found out a way
to figure out the shape of your head
without having to shave it all off.
Science, come on.
We must have figured something out, right?
- It scans the contour of your head.
- I'm sure there's a
fucking filter or something
that figures out.
- The filters always
look shit.
Filters always look shit.
(Garnt laughing)
They always look so cartoonishly bald.
Like Lex Luther bald.
- No bald person looks like this.
- It's like they just take
this fucking Jeff Bezos bald.
- Yeah, everyone's just like
Johnny Sins.
You know what I mean?
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, dude.
They all look like that.
And it's like, no.
- Johnny Sins doesn't even
look like a real bald person.
- He doesn't, right?
- [Connor] What a man, what a man.
The king of bald man jobs.
- Yeah, aside from aside from
Joey getting his haircut,
I watched another anime this past week.
- What did you watch?
- I watched "Jujutsu Kaisen 0."
- Oh you watched the movie.
- In cinemas, yeah.
- How was it?
It was.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Say it.
Say it, Garnt!
- It was okay.
- Yeah.
- Not mid?
- [Garnt] Not mid, not mid.
- I liked it.
I thought it was good.
- It was good, it was good.
It was, it was-
- Did you watch it in 4XD?
- [Garnt] What's 4XD?
- Where they like spit on you
and shake the chair and stuff?
- No, I didn't know that was an option.
- Did they gave that for "Jujutsu Kaisen?"
- [Connor] Yeah, they did.
- Wow.
- They did spit on you.
- They blow air.
- There's just one person like-
- Like they blow air.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
I dunno, I liked the animation.
It was pretty.
- I dunno if watching "Demon
Slayer" has just spoiled me
in terms of like shonen anime films.
- Could be.
(Connor laughing)
But I went in, not with
like the expectations
that it was going to be "Demon
Slayer: Mugen Train" level,
but I did come in knowing
that that was the last shonen
anime film that I had watched
in theaters.
And I came out being just mildly amused
and just impressed by
some animation points.
But at the end of the day it
was the most seven out of 10.
- Yeah, I was gonna say
it's a seven out of 10.
- Was the story good?
- It's okay.
- Uh.
(Joey laughing)
- It was okay.
Like, okay-
- The people in the cinema
next to me were fucking
bawling their eyes out.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- I was like, you good?
- Literally everyone in the cinemas
when I watched "Mugen Train"
was just light sobbing
from every corner of the room.
And I'm just like, oh now?
- I've, I've-
- This woman next to me
was like full on bawling.
And I was like, are you okay?
- Yeah, 'cause to me, "Mugen Train",
the thing that made
"Mugen Train" special was
that it actually felt cannon.
- Yeah.
- You know, it actually
felt like it had a real,
tangible effect on the story.
Whereas I know that "Jujutsu
Kaisen 0" is technically cannon
because it's technically
supposed to be a prequel,
but also it's starring a main character
that we hadn't seen before.
Um, and-
- No, it is cannon.
It's pretty cool.
- No, it is.
- It is cannon, yeah.
- It is cannon, but it didn't
feel like anything I watched
in the movie had any effect
to like anything I watched
in the TV series at all.
- Little bit, little bit.
Very minimal though.
Like mainly to do with the bad guy.
- Mainly to do with the bad guy.
And then I found out
spoilers from the people
I was watching it with
and I was like, oh, okay.
I'm not gonna spoil.
- Don't tell me, yeah.
I'm not gonna spoil, but it had like,
it didn't really have
that much of an effect.
It kind of felt like a
side story, if anything,
rather than actually
having a proper, like,
I should care about all
the things going on.
And I think that's my problem
with a lot shonen anime movies is
that there's zero reason for me to care
about anything going on.
- We spoke about this last
time we spoke about movies.
- Literally every "One Piece" movie.
(Garnt laughing)
- It's a good experience,
but it is a bit odd,
'cause I think it's been number one
at the box office in
Japan for 10 weeks now.
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
- I'm not even surprised.
- These things are just
money printers.
They're just money printers.
- After "Mugen Train," every
industry is eagle vision
on cinemas now.
That's where the money is.
- Yeah, it feels like the
industry is definitely gearing up
more towards movies
'cause like, yeah, we're-
- I mean, "Heaven's Feel"
was like fucking insane
as well for that three month
process of all those movies.
- Yeah, 'cause like when I got invited
to see "Jujutsu Kaisen," I thought,
oh, it's a bit late, isn't it?
Is it still gonna be in cinemas?
'Cause I missed out on seeing "Dune,"
because that was only in cinemas
for like a month and a half
or like maybe even less
in Japanese cinemas.
But with anime movies,
it just seems like it just never goes out.
- Dude, "Mugen Train" was
in cinemas for a year.
- Yeah, like what?
- A year.
- Like how is it, a year later,
people are still seeing it
in cinemas, and they're still
making money off this shit.
I mean, I guess that's why it's
the top grossing anime movie
of all time.
But my time scale for how
long movies are in cinemas
are like completely fucking
destroyed by anime movies
because they just never seem to go out.
They always seem to be in there.
- How long has "Jujutsu Kaisen"
been in cinemas for now?
- [Garnt] A couple months.
- Didn't it come out in,
it came out Christmas Eve?
- Oh shit, so it's almost three months.
- Yeah, almost three months.
- Yep.
- And it doesn't seem like
it's even close,
- Yeah.
it doesn't seem like it's even close.
- Yeah, 'cause they have
showings in 4XD, MXD or whatever,
and have 3D, and they
have all the Dolby Atmos,
and there's a fuck ton going still.
- Jesus Christ.
- Like when I was stuck in Hokkaido,
because the airport has a cinema there,
I was like, oh, maybe
I'll see what's playing.
Literally it was "Jujutsu Kaisen
0" for every single place.
- [Connor] They didn't
have any other stuff?
- No, they didn't have.
- Was it just one screen
or was it multiple screens?
- I believe it was two screens.
- Oh yeah.
Okay, that makes sense.
- Yeah.
'Cause there's a ton of
cinemas all around Tokyo
that have like 20 plus screens
or something ridiculous.
- Yeah.
- And you can watch, there's
tons of foreign films,
so many of them.
- And you can watch "Jujutsu
Kaisen" on seven of them.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, I watched, ah,
"Operation Mincement?"
That's what it's called?
The one with Colin Firth?
- That doesn't sound like a real movie.
- Never heard of that, at all.
- It's about a World War II operation
where they made a fake person,
but they got a real dead body
and gave it fake documents
and then washed it up in Spain.
- Wait, is that like
based off a true story?
- Yeah, it really happened.
- Oh wow.
- Really cool.
Really, really cool story.
- [Joey] That's pretty dope.
- Basically, they wanted
to make Germany think
that the UK was gonna attack
somewhere they weren't.
And so the way they did it was
by floating a body to Spain,
with fake documents on it.
And then Spain leaked it to Germany,
and then Germany thought it was
real stuff.
- Dang.
'Cause they made this
person look so convincing
that they were a real person.
- Jesus.
- That's pretty dope.
- Well that's-
- It's a really cool story,
but the movie was shit.
- Oh, okay, is it a comedy?
(Joey laughing)
- It's a drama, but the problem,
I guess it wasn't shit.
It was a very-
- [Joey] How could you
think that a comedy?
- Five or six out of 10.
- [Joey] Lol.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- It focuses on the personal
drama amongst the people
who are doing the operation.
- Ah.
- [Connor] And so it's
kind of like a love-
- Like human drama biopic.
- [Connor] It's like a
love triangle and shit.
And it's like,
this is a fucking war, what's going on?
- What do we, I didn't, I don't know.
I was very disinterested.
- "The Notebook" of World War II.
- Yeah.
- It was just kinda like, all right.
The thing is so interesting
itself that the whole story,
but obviously there's
not much known about it,
so they obviously had to make a drama
inside of it.
- Build it up.
- And so it's kind of like,
I mean, Colin Firth's great.
He's always great.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But it was just kinda like, all right.
- [Joey] Just meh.
- Yeah.
- Well like, like going
back to what you said
about, yeah, it was shit.
I was having this thought the other day,
because I'm getting so bored
of the word mid, right?
Because it just seems like,
I tweeted out a tweet about
fucking "Demon Slayer"
and the animation.
And somehow that was one of
the most toxic Twitter tweets.
- You tweeted about
"Demon Slayer" animation?
- [Joey] Why would you do that?
- After what happened to me, Garnt?
- I just said "Demon
Slayer" had good animation.
That was it.
(Joey laughing)
I was just like, oh yeah, "Demon Slayer,"
I watched season two,
and I'm like, okay, maybe it
did deserve best animation.
My fucking God.
I literally had to mute
that thread, that thread,
compared to everything
else going on in the world,
that was the thread that I
had to mute in the past week.
- I'm gagging, just thinking
about that comment section.
- People are clowns, right?
It does have the best animation.
It's not even a contest,
but people say there's other
things that are better.
It's not.
Is the story the best?
No.
But people are equating the fact
that they don't like the show,
or they don't like how much
attention it's getting.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Being like, it doesn't
deserve the best animation.
Listen, it does.
Like it just flat out does.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Does that mean that it's a good show?
No, no it doesn't.
- No, no.
Is it a mid shonen
series, like story wise?
Yes, yes it is.
(Garnt gasping)
But the animation is fucking God tier.
- Whoa, whoa.
- I'm not associating
myself with that opinion.
(Garnt laughing)
- Listen, I fucking love
"Demon Slayer," right?
But it's the same reason why I watch porn.
I like what's going on on the screen.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I don't like the plot.
- That "I love Demon Slayer, but"
is the most paper thin,
- "I love Demon Slayer, but"
it's the most paper thin-
it's mid.
- Yeah.
- You heard it here first.
- I fucking, I was so
hype watching it, bro.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- But to sit here and be like,
it's a complex storytelling.
- No, no.
- It's not.
- It's super simple shonen.
I think like-
- It's straightforward.
- What does mid mean to you?
What does mid mean to you?
- Mid means to me that you can watch it
and there are many aspects
of it that you enjoy,
but there's also a lot of aspects about it
that just don't grip you.
Like there's a lot about it that like-
- Like "Jujutsu Kaisen."
- No.
- To me.
- No, 'cause, I was having
this thinking, it seemed like-
- I think the story is mid, right?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- As an overall show, it's good.
- I think the story is, you
know, slightly above mid.
I think it's a solid story.
It does everything.
- Slightly above mid.
(all laughing)
- It is such a fucking meme.
- That's like saying like
that's slightly above shit.
- Listen, I-
- Is mid shit?
- The train movie?
I'm gonna say it, it was boring as fuck.
I was bored outta my mind watching that.
- The whole way?
- No.
Okay, there was bits where it was good,
but like the first-
- First 60%.
- Yeah.
- The first like 70% of that movie,
I was actually like ResidentSleeper, bro.
I was sleeping.
- I agree with you.
- Yeah, I agree.
- Like, Goddamn!
- I think people forget that,
because everyone already
thinks about the last fight
and like the last 30
minutes of that movie.
'Cause the last 30 minutes
were fucking great.
They were fucking amazing.
- Yeah.
The actual part when they
were on the train was to me
pretty, pretty boring.
- It was boring as fuck!
It was pretty boring.
- The part where they
like go into the dreams,
I was just like, snooze.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Literally snooze,
literally snooze, yeah.
- [Connor] It's, yeah.
- Yeah, but like, to me,
I had this realization
that to me, something shit,
when I say, oh yeah, it was pretty shit,
it was a five out of 10.
To me that shit, right?
Whereas I dunno, why-
- Is a five out of 10 shit to you?
- I dunno why.
- To me, that borders on average.
- [Connor] Yeah, but that the thing,
you can-
- But when was the last
five out of 10 thing you've watched?
- You can tell yourself
that five out of 10
in your head means that, but it doesn't.
Five out of 10 means that,
- Right?
'Cause you're never gonna
give anything a one,
unless you really hate it.
- [Joey] Right.
- You never hear anyone
giving a three or a four.
- See, 'cause in my
head like I'm operating
on the MyAnimeList rating score, right?
- So when's the last
time you, in your mind,
gave something a five out of 10?
You could be watched, read, whatever.
Right?
- Okay, because seven out of 10 means
that you didn't hate it,
but you were happy.
Like you had an experience
that you were happy with.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Did it blow you away?
No.
Five out of 10 means that you are not sure
if you wasted your time,
and that's why it feels
weird giving things
that you're like, it's mid, a five out 10.
- 'Cause like I think a one out of 10
isn't even wasting your time.
'Cause at that point-
- [Connor] That's an insult.
- At that point you watch a one out of 10,
you're like, this is just entertaining.
This is so shit.
- Yeah, this so bad that it's good.
- Like you watch "Ex-Arm,"
you watch "Berserk 2016,"
you're like, okay, this is
obviously fucking terrible,
but I'm having a good time watching this
just to shit on it.
- But to me, it's like
five is at the middle
where it's like, all right,
if you do nothing good and nothing bad,
you get a five, right?
It's the most basic.
- No.
- No, to me a five out of
10, when it comes to anime,
to me a five out of 10 is
like I finish watching it,
I feel nothing about it,
and I forget about it in a couple weeks.
- Five out of 10 for me is
like, have I wasted my time?
I'm not sure.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No, no, no, five out 10 to
me is have I wasted my time?
Yes.
This was a waste of time.
It was-
- Right.
- I didn't get-
- But it wasn't horrible, right?
- Yeah, no, no.
- So what would you define as four?
- It's because, huh?
- What would you say four is then?
- Four is, okay, here's four.
(Connor laughing)
- Four to me is like, I'm
going to forget about this,
but all I'm going to
remember about this show
is that it was a waste of my time.
- No, no, because here's how-
(Joey laughing)
Here's how I think why, when
we say what the average,
when we say what the middle of the ground,
what the average score is,
most people will say seven,
even though logically you think it's five.
- It's five, yeah.
- Okay so if it's a five,
it's probably like the lowest
that you will ever finish a show.
'Cause to me, if it's a three or four,
I watch one or two episodes,
and I didn't even finish it,
because there's nothing in
that to grab my attention.
Five is just like, there was
enough for me to finish it
and then I regret finishing
it because it was-
- [Connor] Okay, I understand that.
- Yeah, because there was nothing in there
that made me want to remember
it or left an impact on me.
- But the five out of tens
are like, in my opinion,
they're the worst shows
because they're just thrown
into this pile of like,
oh yeah, that existed.
- What would you give
"Jujutsu Kaisen" out of 10?
- I'd give it like a seven.
- Okay, that's fair then.
- It's because it's like,
- And that's mid, seven?
No, no, I wouldn't consider that mid.
It's okay.
- It's slightly above mid.
- It's okay.
(Garnt laughing)
- See to me, right, when you say seven,
seven to me is like, you were
happy and had fun watching it,
but the moment it's over,
you don't feel compelled
by the show at all.
There's nothing that makes it
really stick in your memory.
It's a good experience
and you don't regret it,
but nothing after the fact
makes you want to actively
think about it.
- Yeah.
- But that's the thing, it's
like with "Jujutsu Kaisen,"
I finished it.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And I had a pretty
good time watching it.
I was like, okay, yeah, this is good.
But when it was finished, I was like,
am I compelled to go read the manga
or like continue it on?
Not exactly.
To me, "My Hero Academia"
is the exact same thing
where season one, yeah, it was great.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- It was cool.
You know, I can see why people enjoyed it.
I had a pretty good time with it.
Am I compelled to continue on with it?
Personally, no.
- What would you give the,
did you watch the new
"Demon Slayer" season yet?
Have you watched it?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- What would you give it?
I, personally, even though I
said the story is not the best,
I still think it's like
an eight or a nine.
- I'd give like solid eight.
- [Connor] It went hard.
- I would give it an 8.5 to nine.
And the reason I say that is-
- We're all in agreement.
The Demon Slayer Councilors Society.
- [Joey] Strong eight, strong eight.
- It was amazing.
- Because I don't agree
that the story is mid,
because a lot of people say the story
of "Demon Slayer" is mid,
and to me "Demon Slayer's" story,
it's as simple as it needs to be, right?
- Yeah.
- I feel like it's as
simple as it needs to be
to make the rest of the good parts shine.
- Mm.
- The problem with "Demon
Slayer" is when you have an arc,
like "Mugen Train", and there are fights
that don't stand out as much,
it's really, really
apparent, that the story
and the characters don't
carry the show as much.
- Mm.
- But with season two,
because half the season was a
fucking full on action fest,
You're like,
- So good.
you're like, fucking hell,
this is like an eight or nine out of 10.
- Yeah.
- That's the point where, okay,
I don't really care
about the story that much
if the action just
fucking slaps this hard.
- Yeah.
- How dare you say-
- You know what I mean?
How dare you say the animation is good.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Wow.
- I don't think we ever talked about that
on the podcast, have we?
- You should be ashamed.
You should be fucking ashamed.
- I'm too afraid to.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Cause I've been on the
other side quite recently.
- Getting canceled about
talking about the animation?
- I'm just trying to
think of a five out of 10.
This is the problem
with trying to remember
a five out of 10 anime show,
is that I don't remember.
That's why they're five
out of 10, you know?
The moment I finish-
- What about manga?
What about manga?
'Cause you read more manga.
'Cause I can remember
- He is Joey the Manga Lad.
most five out of 10 shows.
It's literally, I go to the
list of isekai I've finished,
and a lot of these are
literally five out of 10.
- Even five out of 10 manga,
I just don't remember them.
And that's the problem,
it's so hard to talk
about these kinds of like mediocre,
middle of the ground shows,
it's because unless I
recently re-watch it again,
I'm not gonna remember it.
I'm like, oh yeah, it's probably something
along those lines, but
I wouldn't be able to
concretely tell you this is the reason
why it's a five out of 10.
It's just so impactless
that it's like, oh,
I didn't even know that existed.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- Do you feel bad if you
feel like you've wasted time
watching a show?
- No.
- Um.
- [Connor] Just no.
- You don't?
- No?
- No, I feel like when you start caring
that much about the media, you're,
the media why, sounds like the media,
- [Joey] The media, the system.
- About the stuff you're consuming,
I feel like you almost ruin
a lot of it for yourself.
Like stuff that you might have enjoyed,
you're worried too much
about if you're enjoying it
the whole time.
- Oh, that's kind of where I got to,
unfortunately, with that.
It got to the point
where I was so selective
on what I was watching to
make sure that everything
I was watching was worth my time.
That if I ran into something
that I was like, well,
I just wasted an hour
because of watching these
first three episodes.
Great.
- I dunno if this is like a,
I haven't consciously chosen to do this,
but I've stopped scrolling
or looking for shows.
- Yeah.
- It's just kind of whatever
appears in front of you?
- Whatever is recommended,
whatever is put in my head or-
- I think that's the
best way to consume media
to be honest.
- And honestly,
I've been having a great time.
I feel no pressure.
- I honestly wish,
I honestly wish I could do that because-
- [Connor] You have to watch anime.
- Well, no, it's not even anime.
It's like pretty much every form of media,
and it's not even about me
being like a fucking snob,
wanting to like consume the best shit.
It's literally, I started
really caring about it
when I just didn't have
the time to do everything
I wanted to do, right?
- Yeah.
So like now nowadays, even if
it's just like picking a game,
I want it to be a game I
could properly get into.
Like I don't want-
- But you'll be stuck in this cycle
of constantly worrying if
the game is good enough
for your time and then you never play it.
- You'll never start, yeah.
- You never fucking play anything.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, yeah, I mean, that's why-
- I feel games are way more of a time sink
than an anime on average.
- Yeah. I mean, it depends.
But to me getting into a game,
getting properly absorbed into a game,
it's one of the most magical experiences,
and I love fucking it
- Oh yeah.
when I just get absorbed
into a video game world,
the same way that I get
absorbed into an anime
or absorbed into a manga
or something like that.
- Absolutely.
- And like, to me, I don't know,
because my time is so
precious to me right now,
it sucks that I constantly
have to have this little part
of my head that's just like,
oh, could you be watching
something better that you'd
enjoy maybe a little bit more?
(Joey laughing)
Are you really in the mood for this?
- I don't know.
You optimize your schedule
in every way, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So I feel like the
stuff that you consume
should be the one where
you're like, no pressure,
like whatever you watch,
whatever you play,
doesn't matter if it wasn't
the game of the year.
Doesn't matter if it wasn't
the movie of the year.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Just watch whatever comes
up, have an opinion on it.
I watched that "Don't Look Up."
- Oh yeah.
- What a shit movie.
- The DiCaprio one, right?
- What an awful movie.
- That was a five out of 10.
- I hated that movie.
- You hated that?
- I hated it.
- I heard a lot of people hated it.
- I was so fucking bored.
- Yeah.
- And it went on for an an
hour longer than it needed to.
- Right.
- And, yeah, there was
some funny moments of it.
There was some bits that I chuckled,
but overall I just felt like
I wasted my time.
- A waste of time?
But I was like, I'm glad I watched this
because it gave me, even though I came out
disliking the movie, for some
reason that made me happy.
I was like, yeah, that was shit.
And it was fun getting
to talk to other people
who also thought it was shit.
I don't know, I just liked it.
I liked that I had
that experience.
- I think as well
because, even if you do
consume something that is shit
within that specific medium,
it just broadens your
horizon more on the medium.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And it adds to the
knowledge pool of like, oh,
now that I've consumed
something on the other side
of the spectrum, now I'm a
little bit more knowledgeable
about what makes the
good shit good, right?
- Yeah.
- I'm definitely like that
with music where I'm like,
if it's on fucking Spotify,
I'm just listening to it.
- Right, right.
I watched as well, I watched
Spiderman movie, the new one.
- Oh.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And like, yeah, it was great,
because it was just great,
and I had a good time,
my emotions are way stronger
about "Don't Look Up."
- [Garnt] Really?
- I hated it.
- Right.
- You have more to talk about, right?
- Yeah, I have more,
I watched "No Way Home"
and I had a great time,
but at the end of the day, I've
already forgotten about it,
and I don't care.
And it was, yeah, it was
good, but it was just-
- That was a movie I fucking loved.
- I liked it a lot, but
after I'm done with it,
I'm like, that was everything
I expected it to be.
- Right.
- And I had fun, but I don't
feel strongly about it.
- I think that's the thing
though, the problem is
I think the sweet spot of you
being able to really gush out
about something is like
when it's on two ends
of the spectrum, right?
- Yeah.
- Whereas it's either
so fucking incredible,
10 out of 10 masterpiece
where you can just gush about
your love for it forever.
And then there's the other
side where it's like,
let me tell you about
how absolutely atrocious
this shit was.
- Yeah, dude, I watched,
could you Google this for me, Ashley?
It's Robert Pattinson's movie.
I forgot the name.
Fuck, I watched it like three weeks ago.
- [Ashley] The new one.
- No, no, no, no, it's an old one.
- Must've been a five out of 10.
- Yeah, right?
(Joey laughing)
Must have been a five out of ten.
- [Connor] It was amazing.
- Oh.
- Oh okay, that's just him.
- Was it "Good time?" "Good Time?"
I can't remember what it's called.
- Connor remembers the shit things
and forgets good things apparently.
- What?
- [Ashley] "Good Time."
- "Good Time."
Yeah, dude, "Good Time?"
Please fucking watch "Good Time."
It's so good.
This movie was amazing.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Was it a good time?
- I want you to watch it so
badly so we can talk about it.
- What's it about?
- I don't wanna say anything, but-
- Just go into it blind?
- Have you watched "Uncut Gems?"
- No.
- Yeah.
You know how it's just anxiety simulator?
- It's that.
And like-
- Great.
- [Connor] It is literally
like anxiety simulation.
- Okay.
- It's so good.
It's amazing.
And it's just like a movie
that when you watch it,
I just felt like this was just,
I'm so glad I watched this movie.
I just felt like I had
experienced something special
that a lot of love and care went into,
and that everyone really
just brought their A-game.
It was just amazing.
Please watch it.
- Okay.
It's so good.
A lot of Robert Pattinson's movies-
- Is it still in cinemas?
- No, no, it came out years ago.
- Oh.
- [Ashley] Came out 2017.
- Yeah, yeah.
So, again, go and watch it.
It's really good.
I absolutely adore all of his stuff.
I think he's really
good in a lot of things.
I'm really hype for him as Batman.
- I'm hype for him.
- I'm hype as well.
- Every movie I've watched
with him after "Twilight,"
he chose weird ass roles
that were just so good,
and he just nailed it.
- Yeah.
- But that's what I love about
- So hype for him as Batman.
actors like that though,
because Daniel Radcliffe did
the exact same thing, right?
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- It's like, usually
those like super popular
typecasted actors who are like,
now people are just gonna
know me as this shit forever.
- Yeah.
- So I'm just gonna go
and do all the weird.
- All the weird shit.
- All the weird, artsy,
Daniel Radcliffe movies,
I've seen so many of them
and they're just like,
man, fucking respects, dude.
You can do shit like this.
And now he's doing Broadway shit?
- Yeah.
- He was doing that that
right after, I think.
- It's fucking great.
Yeah, good on you, dude.
- I feel like actors going
weird and doing weird films
is like the actor equivalent
of the YouTuber getting their hair dyed.
(all laughing)
It's like, guys, I want an image change.
I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna
do a bunch of weird shit now.
Right?
- Sure, they've all gone on,
like Shia LaBeouf as well,
doing all the weird
shit afterwards as well.
- Which one did he do?
Nymphoma-?
- "Nymphomaniac."
- That was a weird watch.
- Yeah.
Have you watched that, Garnt?
- No.
- I want Garnt to watch this.
- "Nymphomaniac?"
- What's that about?
(Connor laughing)
- What's the fucking director's name?
It's the really weird-
- You know what a nymphomaniac is, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's about nymphomania.
- You know that's a three parter, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's three part, it's a trilogy?
- No, no, it's two parts, right?
- [Ashley] Lars von Trier.
- Lars von Trier.
Yeah, it's a Lars von Trier film.
- It's two parts, right?
- [Ashley] Two.
- Yeah, two.
- Is it two parts?
- It's two, yeah.
I was like what are you about three parts?
- [Ashley] Uh, yeah, two.
Volume one and two.
- Yeah.
- No, no, no, no.
Not of "Nymphomaniac," of that universe.
- Oh.
No, the one with Shia
LaBeouf movies are two.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I watched them and-
- It's a universe?
- It's a trilogy of Lars von Trier movies,
and "Nymphomaniac" I
think is the third one.
Something like that.
- You, you should see it.
Yeah, right?
It is weird.
- It is a fucking weird movie.
It's uncomfortable, and it-
- It's weird, yeah.
- It's like Lars von Trier
- He's fucking weird.
is known to make some
really disturbing movies.
- [Connor] Very disturbing,
very disturbing.
- And "Nymphomaniac" is probably,
I've seen all of the Lar von Trier movies,
and "Nymphomaniac" is easily
the fucking weirdest one.
And I was like, oh, Shia LaBeouf's in it.
What the fuck?
- You just go from "Even
Stevens," "Shut up, sis,"
and it's like, oh gosh.
Oh God!
Jesus.
- Oh good.
I didn't wish to see
Shia LaBeouf's butt hole
in three different scenes.
But there it is, I guess.
- I didn't mean to watch this movie.
It came on the TV.
- Yeah, where did you, how did you see it?
It was on TV?
- It was on TV.
I was in a hotel, and like-
- Isn't it an X-rated movie?
- I think it was in Bulgaria,
and it was on TV or something.
- You watched it in Bulgaria.
(Joey laughing)
- I know I watched it
in a European country,
and it was on TV at like
2:00am, and I couldn't sleep.
And I watched it just,
I remember just thinking
what the fuck?
- Must have felt like
a fucking fever dream.
- Yeah.
- It was weird.
- Yeah, anything Lars von Trier makes
is a fucking fever dream.
- It's weird, man.
- How do you guys think like
trash TV fits into everything?
Would you call trash T,
what rating would you
give "Kitchen Nightmares"
or something like that?
Or "90 Day Fiance?"
- I think it just depends 'cause people,
it depends if you grew
up on it or not, right?
Were you surrounded-
- I like the character of Gordon Ramsay?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm invested in that character.
I like it.
I know that most of it, especially
in "Kitchen Nightmares,"
are all faked.
I don't a shit.
- Yeah.
- But also that's the thing.
It depends on if you were
raised in a family where
it was a family event to be like,
oh it's Wednesday night, let's
watch "Kitchen Nightmares."
You know, that kind of thing, right?
I didn't grow up in a family
like that.
- No.
So to me, I didn't grow
up with trash TV at all.
So, yeah.
- We never watched it together.
I watched it on YouTube.
- Yeah, so when I watched,
Oh, okay.
So the first time I knew
about "Kitchen Nightmares"
was through YouTube clips, right?
Or any TLC show, right?
I was like, what the
fuck is this, you know?
- Yeah, just 'cause I
knew "Kitchen Nightmares"
because that was literally
when I first saw Gordon Ramsay as well.
It was the British "Kitchen
Nightmares" as well,
which was, you compare
British "Kitchen Nightmares"
to American "Kitchen Nightmares"
and it's like fucking night and day.
(Joey laughing)
Not only the editing,
but just how toned down
Gordon Ramsay is as well.
- Right.
Toned down in the British one?
- Yeah, he's toned down.
- He's chill, he's chill.
It's different, right,
'cause it feels like
in the American one, it
feels like they actually get-
- There's a formula.
- Huh?
It is a formula, but
it feels like they get
the worst of the worst
fucking chefs and restaurants,
actual clowns.
- Yeah.
- To present their dish to Gordon Ramsay.
And it's almost cartoonish in a way.
- Yeah.
- And you look at the British one
and it feels like it's just chefs
who actually give shit a about their food.
Who actually just-
- Who need some advice.
- Yeah.
- A lot of the times Gordon
Ramsey is giving them
genuine advice and maybe
they're too it headstrong
or maybe they're too, you
know, prideful to really listen
to his advice.
Whereas, you know, in America
it actually feels more like
this is not even a reality TV anymore.
This looks so cartoony,
and feels so over the top
that you just don't
even take it seriously.
- I just feel that way about
99% of American trash TV.
- No, you know which one I hate the most?
- [Joey] What?
- I hate it 'cause I used
to also watch it a lot.
The fucking "Pawn Stars."
- Oh yeah.
- What's that one?
(Joey laughing)
- You know it, it's the,
you know, "Pawn Stars."
- It's the one, it's set in Vegas.
- Right.
- It's the one with the bald
guy and someone comes in,
he is like, I've got this
thing worth 20 million dollars,
and he's like, I'll give
you 10 bucks for it.
- Yeah.
- Oh!
- Oh, I thought you said porn stars.
- Like pawn.
- We're British.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We pronounce it the same way, Garnt.
- "Pawn Stars."
- Unfortunately, we're not American
where they're like "Pawn Stars."
- "Pawn Stars."
- I thought it was-
- We say porn.
- Yeah, yeah, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I thought it was a fucking
show about little porn stars.
(Joey laughing)
I was like, what is this reality TV show?
- There's "Pawn Stars,"
and there's also "Hardcore Pawn" as well,
which is the other one that
was a spin off to that.
- There was a British
version of it as well
which is just like-
- What was it called?
Pawn, innit?
- Probably.
- Car Boot Salers
(Joey laughing)
or something like that, right?
- Yeah, that show is just,
'cause it's obviously fake,
but also at the same time,
you're like, it is just cool
just seeing weird brought shit in.
- I've driven past the "Pawn Stars" place
in Vegas.
- But, it's fake.
They don't even film it in there, right?
It's filmed somewhere else.
- They don't actually film it
in there.
They just film B-roll outside of it.
- And it's just like-
- Because it's in the
most ghetto part of Vegas.
It's so scary.
- And then, you know, there'll
be, this guy comes in.
He'll be like, I have
this mummified corpse
that's been sitting in my
grandma's attic in Nevada.
You're like, great.
He's like, oh, you know, I know an expert.
I'm gonna bring him down.
- Yeah.
And 10 seconds later, the
experts then he's like,
well it is a mummified corpse.
It's worth about $50,000.
And then he goes, I'll
give you 20 bucks for it.
(Joey laughing)
What am I gonna do with
the mummified corpse?
What are we gonna do with that?
That's just so dumb.
The whole formula is shit.
- And then they just walk out angrily.
It's like, you're missing
out on a great deal, man.
- Yeah, I mean, what I didn't
understand about "Pawn Stars"
is when they started
introducing story lines, like-
(Joey laughing)
- B Plots, they're B Plots.
- Yeah, they're would be
B-Line plots with their family
that would get resolved in an episode.
- Yeah.
- Like it's an episode of "Happy Days"
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- Same as "Storage Wars" as well.
- Oh my God, I remember "Storage Wars."
- That was so big in the UK.
The American one played on UK television
so fucking much.
- Really?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It was so popular, it was ridiculous.
- Yeah, I just, yeah, thinking
back on it I used, yeah,
that was the one actually trash TV
that came on Australian TV all the time.
And my dad was obsessed with it.
- I just loved it,
'cause there would literally
be a pile of shit in this room,
and these guys be like
sell that for 50 bucks,
sell that for 20 bucks.
Like where are you gonna sell this to?
There's like a used bed sheet, he's like,
that's five bucks right there.
It's like, no, it's not.
You're not selling this for five bucks.
- What if, though, it's all connected?
The trash TV universe where they-
- The trash TV universe.
- In "Storage Wars" they take all the shit
and then they go to the "Pawn Stars" place
to sell it off.
(Garnt laughing)
- I just don't get, I don't get it.
'Cause half the time, you know,
of course there'll be these fake ones
that'll be like, this guy has a lot full
of perfect rarity Charizards
in perfect grade.
- Yeah.
It's like, well obviously
we can sell those.
But other times there's
just lots or something
where it's just all shit.
And you're like, even if
you could make a profit
selling this, surely the amount of time
to get rid of all of this shit and sell it
is just not worth it.
- [Joey] No.
- Yeah, you could sell the pack
of AA batteries for 10 bucks
if you really wanted
to, but why would you?
Where are you gonna sell this to?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Are you shipping it?
Surely that has to be taken
into account.
- Japan.
- This is the only country
where I see that working,
you know, where you can
actually sell the stuff
and people will buy it and reuse it.
- They do have storage lots in Japan.
I don't think they sell them, do they?
When they, when they-
- No.
- I don't, I'm pretty
sure they don't sell them.
- They actually use storage
for storage purposes.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, but the storage lots,
I think if somebody doesn't collect it,
I think they just get
rid of all the stuff.
- [Joey] Yeah, they just throw it all out.
- Don't think they sell
them to the public,
which would be shame.
'Cause we need a Japan
"Storage Wars" version.
That would be-
- "Storage Wars!"
- [Connor] Dude, that would be epic.
Tanaka-san thinks
he can get a great deal.
- Directed by Hosoda Mamoru.
- No, I can't, what?
I think I know more
American reality TV shows
than I know British reality TV shows.
I can't think of many-
- We have-
- You guys have
"Naked Attraction."
- You know the one-
- We do have
"Naked Attraction."
- No, no, no, no-
- I love that show.
- When I went back to the
UK, that was still on TV.
It was still airing
on Channel 4.
- I love that show.
- You know, the ones that actually I,
there's a reality TV show
where you feel bad watching it.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- But even if it's, I dunno
how much of it's fake,
but you know the debt collectors one?
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's the one where I'm
always, even if this is fake,
should we really be
making storylines?
- Which one is that one?
- There's a bunch in the UK.
We fucking love debt collecting shows
in the UK for some reason.
(Garnt laughing)
- We love watching debt collectors
as long as we're not
on the butt end of it.
- So what's the premise?
- Just-
- They go and collect debts.
- It's just like Jim
owes the bank $50,000.
So Jeremy over here is
gonna go over to his house
and collect it.
Let's see what happens.
- But in the British one, it's just
some guy goes to the house,
hey, we've come here to get the stuff,
and they're like, fuck off, mate.
No, you're not fucking getting my thing.
Fuck right off.
And they're like, they've
got a high magistrates
court notice to collect this stuff.
(Joey laughing)
If they don't, they'll
start collecting things
off the property.
And then the police turn up
and then it's just fucked.
'Cause it's like, oh these poor people
who've had some horrible circumstance,
and then we're just shoving
cameras in their face
while their apartments being ransacked
and they're selling the stuff off.
Yeah, they should have
- It's like how do you feel?
paid their debts.
Tell me how you feel.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, they probably
should pay their debts.
But wouldn't everyone pay
their debts if they could?
- [Ashley] Wait, is it called
"Can't Pay? We'll Take It Away?"
- That's it?
What a stupid name.
- "Can't Pay? We'll Take It Away?"
- I have never heard of that name before.
- You've watched it.
It's on Channel 5.
- Day in the life
of a repo man.
- I don't watch Channel 5.
- I'm gonna send you links.
- I don't think I've ever
watched a single program.
on Channel 5.
- I guarantee if you watch
one, you'll get hooked.
- [Joey] Is Channel 5
the trash TV channel?
- It's just the trash channel.
(Joey laughing)
- It's so addictive watching this stuff.
I dunno why,
- Like to me Channel 4-
you just can't help yourself.
- But to me like Channel 4 is
where a lot of the trash TV goes.
- Yeah.
- Even though I can't think of any.
- No, Channel 4 has good stuff too though.
- Yeah, but Channel 4 is,
I think Channel 4 is actually
one of the best channels.
It has the widest range.
It seems to be the most
experimental as well.
BBC is just very standard.
Here's your fucking "Doctor Who."
- [Connor] "The Voice."
- Here's "The Voice" .
ITV is just like here's
"X Factor" once again.
That's a reality TV show actually.
- [Connor] "Britain's Got Talent"
- Yeah, that's a reality TV show.
- Yeah, I completely forgot.
That's reality TV show times
a hundred though, right?
- But no one cares about singing reality.
Does is "X Factor" still going?
- [Garnt] Huh?
- Does anyone, is "X
Factor" still happening?
- Oh yeah, I'm sure.
- I'm pretty sure it's still happening.
- [Connor] But does anyone give a fuck?
- "Love Island" as well?
"Love island," is that ITV?
I feel like that's ITV.
- [Connor] It is ITV.
- Yeah, so you got like, I feel-
- But that's really
popular America as well,
the British one.
- Yeah.
- Is it?
- It's really popular in America.
- [Joey] Yeah, it is.
- Oh, "The Great British
Bake Off" as well.
I completely forgot about that.
- Which can't be called
Bake Off in the US.
- Really?
- One of the US brands has the trademark.
- [Joey] Oh, like Easy Bake?
- One of them has the
trademark to "Bake Off."
- [Garnt] Bake Off.
- So it's called
something else in America,
and they've had to-
- [Garnt] Cook off?
- Something.
They've had to actually, on Netflix,
they've had to animate over
certain parts of the show where,
the trophy.
(Joey laughing)
They did CGI where they
changed what the trophy said.
- Wow.
- [Ashley] Oh, its called "The
Great American Baking Show."
- Yeah.
- "The Great American
Baking Show!"
- What?
Yeah, because they didn't have the rights
for the word bake off.
- Oh, wow.
'Cause for some reason a
company owns the rights
for the word bake off, which is weird.
So yeah, they changed it.
So that is popular in the US,
but it's called technically
something different.
- The baking show.
- The Great British Baking Show.
Just doesn't roll off in tongues as well.
- It sounds so stiff.
- I know, right?
I know.
Does Australia have any reality TV shows?
- I mean, we've got "Australian Idol"
and "The Voice Australia"
and all that shit.
- How did "The Voice" get popular?
At which point in time did we decide
we need more than one
singing reality TV show.
When was "X Factor" just not enough.
- I think it's because
shows like "X Factor"
and "American Idol"
where a lot of the times
there was contention of
are they judging them
on their actual singing
or are they judging them
on their performance?
- Yeah.
So people are like, we want to know
if they can actually sing
and looks don't matter.
You know?
Like that whole fucking,
you know, inclusive thing.
- I just hate how they treat
you, the audience as idiots
and feed you these garbage storylines.
- Yeah.
- I also get confused about the judges
on a lot of these shows.
- "X Factor" has, or
"Britain's Got Talent,"
has fucking ruined so
many fucking songs for me.
Just because they use
at the emotional point.
If I hear "You Raise Me
Up" one more fucking time.
(Joey laughing)
It's always "You Raise Me Up" right?
Yeah, like Golden Buzzer
"You Raise Me Up."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like the "X Factor,"
wait, they didn't win, Susan Boyle, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Did Susan Boyle win?
No, she came second, right?
- I can't remember.
- Did Susan Boyle win?
- So that is the peak
of how TV manipulates-
- Yeah.
- Us to just wanna, you know,
they'll give you an underdog,
and they've got a sad story.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Oh no, I've never had a boyfriend.
Oh, oh no.
- Yeah, yeah.
You know, and the show doesn't give a shit
they haven't had a boyfriend,
but they're like, look audience care.
Care about this, care about this.
They do it all the time as
well with military stuff.
- Yeah.
- You know, they'll be
someone who wants to compete
who maybe like served in
Afghanistan or something.
And instead of just being
like, hey, this is the talent.
It's like, no, you are the
guy who went to Afghanistan.
Your whole identity is
about going to Afghanistan,
and you're doing this for your
troops back in Afghanistan,
'cause their one last wish
is to see you perform.
That's what they do, that's what they do.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I was watching a thing
with Chris in the hotel room,
and it was a "Britain's Got Talent" person
who was performing magic, and
they served in the military.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it was just insulting
how they almost shoved it
down your throat.
This is the guy's only
reality as a human being,
that he served in a war.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- Can we not just be people?
Do we have to just shove down
these suggestible stories?
- How about you follow
the name of your show
and just be like, do you have a talent?
Yes or no?
- But this is not about that.
It's about how's your story compelling.
- Yeah.
- So in this magic show,
this guy's doing these tricks and stuff,
and not to minimize it,
but it was almost beat
for beat predictable.
and there's this one
trick where he was doing,
and he was like, oh, look the
clock and tell me the time.
And so right before the
point of this trick goes,
I was like Chris, 'cause
Chris is watching it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I was like, I bet
it's the time where one
of his friends died or
something in the war.
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah.
- I shit you not, two
seconds later he's like,
that's the time when my friend passed.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- Okay, don't get me wrong.
I wanna say that that is
obviously horrific and stuff.
But the fact that they're
using this as like bait for us.
- It's almost even trivializes it,
because it doesn't feel real.
The impact is gone, because
it feels so manufactured.
- They might as well have
just put up a cue card
to be like now cry.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Again, I wanna make sure
I'm not diminishing it.
Or trying to minimize
it or make it seem like-
- It's not on the guy, it's
on the editors of the show.
- It's on the producers.
- The shows probably heard
this story or something,
and they were like, yo, play that up,
play that up.
- Yeah.
Dude, people wanna fucking cry, man.
- Yeah, because it's been
proven plenty of times
that the auditions that we see televised
in front of a live audience,
isn't actually the first audition.
They go through several
stages with the producers.
I guarantee he was doing that magic trick,
and one of the producers
heavily suggested,
yo, you should, you should-
- We don't know this.
Speculation, by the way.
- Speculation, speculation.
In my mind,
I feel like one of the
producers just went,
you know, I feel like
you should kind of try
to integrate that story line
into your magic trick somehow.
- [Connor] Could be.
- You know.
- There's definitely kinda
stuff that producers would do.
We've seen, you know,
if you ever look at the,
people have released
the contracts and stuff,
they're pretty predatory contracts.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- A lot of the time, I can't
remember which one it was,
either one of these shows,
one of the British ones,
by signing the contract,
they owned everything
that you would make that you
would self-publish online
or something.
- I think it was "American Idol."
- One of them.
- One of those, yeah.
- So if you went to even audition
and you posted content
online, if they wanted to,
they could turn around and
be like, hey, that's ours.
That's ours, bro.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's just fucked.
- Yeah.
- [Ashley] Could be
"Britain's Got Talent."
- Yeah.
- I think it might have been
"Britain's Got Talent."
- I think it was 'cause I saw
the YouTube video about it.
- Yeah.
- [Ashley] Also, Susan Boyle didn't win.
She lost out to Diversity.
- That's right, the people who did the,
I remember this.
- Oh, okay.
- It was like a big,
because I think everyone at the time,
I remember when this was
happening when I was younger,
and everyone was like, oh
Susan Boyle's gonna win.
So there was a big effort to
make it so that she didn't win,
or that was public opinion.
- Right, right, right.
This is when people gave
a shit about reality TV.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Now life is the reality TV.
We don't need this shit.
We, our life-
- Just log onto our fucking Twitter,
and you get to see reality TV.
- Yeah.
- Where's where's Susan Boyle now?
Hopefully doing well for herself,
but no one's talking about her.
That's for sure.
- Well, I would like
to go back to the times
when we could just shit on reality TV,
and that just have like
zero effect on our lives.
- Yeah.
- That's the good old days for me.
- This episode is
sponsored by a Manscaped.
- Splish, splash.
I was taking a bath, and I
noticed I have beautiful balls.
- You do, Connor.
You do.
- Our friends at Manscaped TM,
the global leader in
below the waist hygiene
are turning men's shower dreams
into their favorite routine
with the all new, ultra
premium collection.
- [Joey] Damn!
- [Connor] This all in one
hygiene, skin and hair bundle
is designed to upgrade the
everyday men's shower routine
from head to toe.
- Ooo.
Your skin, hair and balls deserve this.
Save big by going to
manscaped.com for 20% off,
plus free shipping with
the code "trashtaste."
- So Manscaped recently
just released a deodorant,
and I gotta say, guys, this
is what a sigma male's semen
smells like.
- Oh my gosh.
(Joey laughing)
- Oh.
- You should know as well, gentlemen,
that Manscaped has started
doing lip balms as well,
which is good
- Ooh.
because especially during
like the winter time
in Japan, the air is very, very dry
and I get chapped lips like crazy.
So get 20% off plus free shipping
with the code "trashtaste"
at manscaped.com.
That's 20% off
plus free shipping
- Woo!
with our code "trashtaste"
at manscaped.com.
It's time to get wet and clean
with your new Manscaped shower routine.
- This bundle will change your life.
Back to the episode.
- Have you ever thought about
going on a show like that, or?
- That's a great question, Joey.
Yeah, no.
Part of me is like, okay,
I saw a guy on YouTube, I
think I showed you guys.
He went on a show, playing a character
and then like just making
fun of the whole process
and like with secret camera
and stuff, showing it.
- [Joey] Oh really?
- Yeah, but then I think the
show took everything down.
- Oh, yeah.
- But it was very-
- Because he signed the contract.
- You had to sign the contract
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
to get on.
But a part of me has thought,
I wonder if I made up a storyline
and I really committed to it,
how easy would it be to get on TV?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I think it would be pretty easy.
Which comedian did it?
A British one did it, didn't he?
- Did he?
- I wouldn't put a past British comedian.
- Which one was it?
Fuck.
He made up like a storyline
about, I think it was, oh,
which comedian was it?
Was it?
- [Ashley] (indistinct)
- Oh, British comedian who
went on "Britain's got Talent"
and there was like,
I don't want say the
storyline in case I'm wrong.
- [Ashley] Daliso Chaponda?
Oh hold on, let me Google.
Let me do a bit more.
- [Garnt] Not sure.
- Give us a second.
Give us sec.
- [Ashley] What British comedian?
- He made it so that his,
I think his backstory was a
Holocaust survivor or something.
- Really?
- Oh.
- Yeah, yeah, something like that
or something like Jewish or something.
I remember it was like that.
- Well, while he's searching,
guess I'll add onto the conversation.
But yeah, I don't know why
people would want to go
on reality TV shows now
when you can just post
yourself up on YouTube.
I feel like that need to have
your five seconds of fame is,
that need is disappearing,
because at any moment in
time you post a TikTok,
you can get like a few million views,
at a complete chance, right?
- Yeah.
- Well, reality TV has figured this out.
That's why they often recruit
people on social media.
- Yeah.
- Oh, really?
- They go on social media
and like DM them, like,
hey, we're from "Britain's Got Talent."
Would you be interested in auditioning?
We can guarantee you to
get to the second judges
or something.
- Ah.
- Sneaky motherfuckers.
- Well, yeah.
Have you not watched clips
of the talent shows recently?
It feels-
- I haven't actually.
- It feels less like a talent
show and more like, hey!
'Cause there's people who
are from all over the world,
like American and Canadian,
it just seems like they're
just getting anyone
who does anything interesting
to come on.
- Right.
- And who has a compelling
story supposedly.
- Yeah.
It's more like they're less
so a talent show of the people
and more a talent show
to just amuse the people
where they just get acts
from across the world.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then just loosely
tie together a story.
- It's the real YouTube Rewind now
since YouTube Rewind
isn't a thing anymore.
(Joey laughing)
- The talented people Rewind.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] I'll have to find it after.
- Okay.
- But what was the story then was,
so he made up that he
was a Holocaust victim,
and-
- Can I have your phone?
I can try and Google it.
- Okay.
I might remember.
- Oh, here we go.
Yeah, Lee Nelson.
Yeah, it was by Channel 4.
- What?
- It was this one.
Look at the thumbnail.
- Oh my God, wow.
- Oh!
- And I think he made up a fake storyline
about being a rabbi and something,
and then whatnot and Channel 4 posted it.
(Garnt laughing)
It was part of "Balls of Steel" I think.
- "Balls of Steel," yeah.
- Oh, I remember "Balls of Steel."
I didn't even know that
was still going on, geez.
- It's not, this is from a while back.
- Oh, okay.
- I remember he made up some story
about being a Hebrew rabbi
and playing a bunch of
generic sympathy cards
and yeah.
- Oh wow.
And, it was really easy for him to get on.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then I think he
got to the live show.
I can't remember what happened, exactly.
I think he then came out or something.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It was, yeah.
But it was just showing how
easy it is to fake stuff.
- Yeah, I mean, 'cause I haven't watched
much reality TV show, not much
like of these talent shows,
I should say, as much as I used to
because before it felt like
everyone was talking about it,
especially when you lived in England.
- It was inescapable.
- Yeah, everyone was talking
about who's gonna win
"Britain's Got Talent" or "X Factor?"
Now it just feels like,
I don't know if its just my
social circle has changed
or if the viewership has genuinely
just had a sharp drop off.
But like I rarely hear anyone talking
about these big talent shows anymore.
- No one cares.
- Because no one really,
the demographic of watching TV now
is just completely shifted, I feel.
- TV's just background noise now.
- Yeah.
- That's it.
No one actually gives a shit
about what's going on on TV.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I feel, you know-
- Oh, at least people under 40.
- Yeah, I feel like people
nowadays would rather,
well obviously, would rather get
on a fucking MrBeast video
or something, you know?
- Totally, yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
- You know, it is weird, actually.
I had this thought the other day where-
- That's the new "America's Got Talent."
(Joey laughing)
- I did have this thought the other day,
and correct me if I've
already talked about this
on the podcast 'cause I can't
remember if I have or not,
but it feels like YouTube in a sense has,
because the internet moves so fast,
YouTube has become the new TV.
And it's almost like TikTok
that has become the new YouTube
in a sense, where TikTok is
this big, rising piece of media.
And remember back in the
day where every YouTuber,
you know you have made it as a YouTuber
if you could appear on TV,
if you could appear on old media.
- Yeah.
- Nowadays it feels like
every TikTok is trying
to make a name for themselves
on YouTube.
- On YouTube.
And it's like YouTube that
is the established media
and the established platform.
- Yeah.
I definitely think so, yeah.
- I agree.
Just like another transition
of, just weird, I don't know.
But at the same time as well, it's almost,
there's a lot of YouTubers
now doing the opposite
where they're trying to
jump onto TikTok now,
and making a name for themselves there
because they think, you know,
it's the whole grass is greener
on the other side concept, right?
Where it's like, which
is the real main source
of income now?
- How many YouTubers do you know?
'Cause I don't know many aside from,
I think Hank Green's
the only one I've seen
a lot on TikTok and like YouTube shorts.
- He's really fun to watch.
- [Ashley] Hank Green is moving
away from TikTok to like-
- He's going to Instagram shorts
or whatever the thing now, isn't it?
- I've seen fucking Ray William
Johnson on TikTok a lot.
- Oh my God.
Seeing Ray William Johnson just have
his revival.
- Dude, seeing Ray William,
Dude, seeing Ray William
Johnson do =3 content
on TikTok is like insane to me.
- It's so weird because it
is literally just =3 content,
right?
- Yeah.
This is the shit he was making
15 years ago on YouTube.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Connor] It is weird.
- And all these new gen
kids are just like, hey,
have you heard of this
hilarious, new wacky guy
called Ray William Johnson.
- I don't think anyone's
calling it hilarious.
- Well, I mean it's making numbers though.
- I know, I know.
- Yeah, surprisingly.
- A lot of things made numbers
on TikTok that are shit.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- Not saying his are shit, but I mean.
(Garnt laughing)
- Are you saying it's just okay?
- It's mid, it's mid.
- It's mid?
- Ray William Johnson is-
- Seven out of 10?
Is it actual mid or you
know, or is it five out 10?
(Joey laughing)
- It's mid.
- What's mid content on TikTok?
Ray William Johnson.
- Oh my God.
- I hate my life.
- But hey, if you'd like
to support the show,
then go to our Patreon.
Patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit,
and if your hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
- 'Til next week where we
shit and fart everywhere.
- Bye.
(mellow music)